I want to let you know I will be in Las
Vegas this weekend October 27th and 28th
at Resorts World we'll be excited to see
you there as well dates in Norfolk
Virginia
ronok Virginia Huntington West Virginia
Evansville Indiana Huntsville Alabama
and Atlanta Georgia those are all on
sale now Theo van.com T Ur that's
theovon
docomo thank you for the support
today's guest is a garbage man um out of
Staten Island uh recently voted one of
America's top 70 Islands um he is a man
who spent 20 years in the gar business
and he knows it he knows it baby he
knows pales and bins baby pales and Bin
he's done it all he collected garbage in
New York City and outside of the city
we're going to learn everything you want
to know
about it today's guest is garbage man Mr
Wayne
Owen that Li on
[Music]
me I'll sit and tell you my
story
shine on
me and I will find a song
singing
Wayne Owen what's up too thanks for
having me yeah thanks for coming in dude
so um you are a you are a you're a
garbage man correct do you guys have a
term that you guys use within the
industry well we used to you know we
used to go with sanitation engineer okay
that was our thing it made just sound a
little more like needed and wanted yeah
compared to a garbage man yeah and I
guess we'll find out I guess even
through the course of this chat if it's
does you know where does it kind of land
I think you know and that's one of the
reasons yeah I I just want to learn all
about the industry so you um you in what
area were you in I started in Manhattan
grew up in St Island okay um started in
Manhattan I did almost two years and
then switched over to Staten Island and
finished my career there did 18 18 years
in Stan out damn you did 18 Years bro
thank you for your service BR first of
all so how do you get into it how does
it even start like is it a family thing
like your father picks you you know just
like picks you up when you're young and
puts you in a recycling bin or
something like you know how does it is
no it's it's Ru with them in New York
like I you know you take the city tests
okay College don't work out you fall
back on a city job you know sanitation
police you know fireman so those are
different city tests so those are
different options yep and you different
test okay so a lot of people that don't
go to college in New York they'll fall
back into that and those are one of the
options correct so you take a different
test so you took a sanitation test yes
wow and that was it was sad but it was
it was a joke really like one of the
questions that I'll never forget never
forget how would you pick up this pile
of dirt and there was like a garbage
truck like you can't use that and then
there was like a shovel with a broom
which of course that's what you would
use and then just like a rake like just
craziness oh yeah it's like but people
get these things wrong man you never
oh yeah you see somebody raking dirt all
the time you know and you used to yell a
slur at him out the window if you're me
but um so you take the test is it how
many people go take the test do you take
it at like a center do you is it like
it's not like where do they do it it's
not like a m MSG or something like that
thing huh no they use like public
schools okay like anything that they
have available high schools grammar
school whatever they have okay so you
roll up like the night before do you get
a lot of sleep do you like show up with
like you know are you kind of preparing
for it or you think it's going to be so
easy no yeah they get you the book like
they have a book to take the test Okay
and like after the second page you're
like all right this is this is I can't
read this book oh damn it's worse than
when you went into reading the book
you're like wait what what's going on
you know so yeah they you know my test a
100,000 over 100,000 people signed up
but they did a lottery so and everybody
has to pay the $30 $35 whatever it is
when you sign up you have to pay yeah
you send your you know your form in with
the money but my test they only and they
only did it this one time they only let
30,000 people take the test so those
other 70,000 didn't even get to take it
damn but they still M took their money
damn dude it's you know it's just like
anything else oh yes they get their
money in they'll get their money wow bro
that's crazy yeah so now you got 70,000
people who are pissed at the city you
know wow okay okay so you take the test
you're in there you you now how long
does it take to get your
score takes a you know they give you a
few months I'd say what yeah a few
months until you get your score I mean
theyo come on if I I wish I was trying
to get a the test to bring it here yeah
really it was a joke and I was actually
in there with high school friends and
they were all running out I was the last
dude in the T like I'm like what's going
on here and I'm not the smartest you
know guy in the world but me neither I'm
like what is going on so I rushed
through the last two questions yeah
guess which ones I got wrong that those
two that's it wow so I got a 103 out of
105 almost a perfect score oh dang okay
so now are you looked at like uh you
come in as a pretty high rank then like
are you like yeah so they give like uh
veterans and stuff extra like credit you
know well deserved and like I think my
list I want to say was like 348 okay out
of you know the 30,000 or 15 I forget
what the number was you in the top 4
yeah wow okay I was hired within a year
okay so you so you still are waiting a
year to get hired yeah and what is why
is this is there no job positions what
is it is it a busy industry yeah well
they just you got to wait till people
retire oh okay you know they have a set
number and that's what they go by okay
all right so you're so somebody finally
retires or something happens to them and
then uh now you get called in right yeah
where were you when you got the call I
was probably just home doing something
stupid yeah yeah I you know I've done
that I was still working in Manhattan
doing like I was a court runner for my
cousin okay so I you know I was working
yeah but you know my mother I said
listen you could be retired in 20 years
you got to take it I was 21 wow I wanted
to you know you know what 21 year olds
do yeah
nothing yeah dude it's great no but you
want to go out and party and like that's
where your life starts right you know
like all parties and but I grew up in
Stan Island where we were going to bars
of 16 17 years old right so you I did
all that yeah and so who yeah did your
mother say look I think this is
something you should do oh no she was
like no you're doing this oh wow but
thankfully enough cuz she saw the end of
it right she said you want to be working
till you know 60 70 80 years old you
know is that really what you want yeah
so there's there is the light at the
end but you got to Andy do frame yeah
listen it's better than any other job
I'll put it that way wow okay okay well
I got to know more then man so all right
so you get in you're hired you're you're
excited you get your first day like how
does that really go and do you go to
like a training camp or whatever do you
guys yeah they send you for the driving
TR uh training okay and they teach you
on dumb trucks okay so that's like two
three weeks that you do your road test
you get your CDL you know your license
to drive the trucks okay now then like
two days they'll bring out and this was
in randle's Island okay and they I think
they did two days they bring a garbage
truck out there okay there's two
steering wheels there's two steering
wheels in the truck there's two steering
wheels like pick which one you would use
no huh well no it all depended on what
street you were on like if you were
picking the right right side of the
street up you could drive from the right
so you're close wow you know so you can
know cuz that's the biggest thing on the
job you got to put that thing where your
partner wants it to make the day go
easier okay if I got to start dragging
garbage around cars and everything else
now we're not having a good day and then
when you get back in the truck there's
beef when you in the cabin yeah oh yeah
wow yeah I I there were a few guys that
and they're good friends of mine but I
would let them know yeah beautiful oh
yeah we need that that's what we need to
see is like instead of Cash Cab we need
to see uh you know yeah that would be oh
yeah sanitation cab violence bro yeah
there was some bad ones yeah that's
beautiful bro no well years ago when I
first got on they used to have like a
one bench like across the the truck okay
they got rid of those so it's just a
left side and a right side okay you
mostly drive from the left and Manhattan
okay you know driving from the right
that was frowned upon it just cuz
everything is different from driving to
on the right side you got it it's a
whole different driving situation oh
yeah every now and then you meet some
fell trying to drive from the right you
know saying nothing but but in Sten
Island it was like a a law like you had
to drive from the right okay so there's
certain places where you got to get over
to the so in that instance you would
just get over to the other side of the
car and for that length of the the truck
yeah there's like a little button you
hit it just switches to now you drive
from that side wow do today's trucks
still have that yes okay okay great okay
cool I didn't know that man that's real
interesting because yeah dude one time I
had to take a driver's head or whatever
and they had the dude over there you
know and this I think the car I was in
was like a um it was a Toyota Tel bro
and a trunk was missing I remember in
the dude's car so there was this total
wind current like constantly like it
like just happening in the vehicle you
know and uh and yeah and I remember
driving that just out of sheer fear like
this guy's out of his mind you
know and he'd pop The Brak and kind of
smile at me and I'm like this
dude's flirting with me bro I'm
trying to learn you know and this dude's
trying to you know touch a child or
whatever all right so you get the first
day man how does your first day on the
job go they literally so all my garage
they tell you hey show up on this time
6:00 a.m. uh Westside 30th Avenue you
know Manhattan 6 was my first garage so
I'm like all right over near uh Javit
Center okay all right so it's right
right a block down from there okay so
you get down there do you go down there
a lot or no no okay I I when you work in
Manhattan you want to stay out of
Manhattan okay you deal with it all week
you deal with nonsense anytime I worked
at Manhattan I just never wanted a party
in Manhattan yeah couldn't stand it all
right so you get down there yeah so I
get there and you know meeting all these
guys yeah I met a few when I signed up
the new guys we came in with I think
like 11 new guys wow so I knew them by
face I didn't really get to know anybody
oh yeah I just watched Band of Brothers
have you seen that no oh that's so good
no and you and you're you're meeting
like you know there's some oldtimers on
there that don't like the new kids
coming in really huh yeah they got like
you know they grumbling grumbling you
know Junior scum guys yeah yeah
scabs or whatever so they're like all
right here they hand me piece of paper
and they said go pick this guy up on 2nd
and 20th so we had these sections all
around Manhattan where guys would go cuz
the garage wasn't big where I was at
okay so you would have section guys show
up there garage guys show up at the
garage that I was at okay and I'm like
wait I had to like think to myself like
I'm going to drive this garbage truck
never drove in a city street where we
were driving up randoms Island we were
going in a circle okay so now you're
putting cars people so you're in the
downtown yeah and now they're like oh go
pick up this partner dang bro never
drove a truck in Manhattan let on you
you've probably driven a car or been in
a car in Manhattan it's not fun oh it's
alarming it's crazy and so now you're
driving the truck and
is Jesus
Christ scary you're your first day you
know your whole thing is the mirrors you
know worrying about you it's a truck you
know it's not a car yeah I got there
okay let's put it that way all right I
was all right I didn't hit nobody no
hurt anybody um and I picked this dude
up okay you know probably 35 years on
the job oh he's been in there huh
scraggly looking guy big beard yeah come
on kid you're with me I'm like ah here
we go oh come on kid he calls you huh
yeah so you know what you're falling
into there right he's suddenly set in
the stone you know he might have been
one of the drivers guys where you were
at
might the way he said it kind of scared
me you know he I bet if you pluck a hair
out of his beard and test it for nyear
olds who know who knows what'll come
back you know but yeah Bing um but yeah
dude and everybody's like looking at you
wow cuz it's like you got stuck with
this guy oh really huh so that's right
away I'm like oh man all right and like
rule of thumb first thing they teach you
is do not stand behind the truck while
the back of the truck is cycling okay it
this dude was looking for everything in
the truck really D we he had all kinds
of in his beard oh it was nasty and
he didn't even care like it was just
like it was
awful just back there just freaking
catching that high time flying out he's
hey you looking for like and looking at
me like I'm not in there with him like
I'm just throwing it in to get rid of it
dude I'm not here to dig through it
pulling out like spider man figures like
you yeah like crazy oh yeah and
that would go right in line with one of
those kids exactly exactly driv a
teacher definitely that was his first
job so he's just back there just
collecting samples from the area huh oh
and now we need he gets back in the
truck like does it what's the inside of
the cab does it smell pretty bad in
there it's a mess yeah you know until
you get your own truck like I had you
know once I got a truck where you get
time on the job you get a route like
dude there cleaning supplies like we
wiped our truck down every day it was
spotless in it right but when you had
guys that just didn't give a crap yeah
you know they just it was filth man oh
you know and what kind of gear are you
wearing what kind of gear is a New York
city garbage
man uh sanitation engineer what type of
gear are y'all locked in just regular
you know Dicky pants with a t-shirt
Jesus winter sweatshirts you know not a
wet suit or not like that no you there
days you needed it oh I bet yeah it was
when it rained it sucked
oh yeah I would think you would go full
plastic you know like well gloves and
boots were like number one yeah that was
always like that's where you spent your
money okay your pants it's it is what it
is yeah you go wash those oh okay so now
you got so you got this kind of guy
rolling with you and how long does that
shift go I was out there for a while
that first day really cuz he's digging
he's looking for you know Treasures oh
this dude really so he's a real hun
there a 5 six seven hour you know route
where normally a routes take about two
hours okay wow really yeah so this guy's
just out there and he just likes to
collect now some of these men just
really collectors and they kind of hide
masquerading as uh sanitation workers
they do that or that some of these guys
get the stuff and sell it wow they have
businesses man really yeah they go to
like you know flea markets and yeah
dude you have no idea man oh one dude in
Staten Island I hate to even give him
the shout out cuz he's a douchebag but
anyway yeah him but yeah tell me
dude he you it was like sordan son on
his roof leaving the garage some days
like he' take you know Furniture this
that
everything and you would catch him at
the flea market ah and but dude listen
from what was told he had over a million
dollars from what he collected and sold
in a bank account nuh-uh yep wow so you
worked in Manhattan and you worked
Staten Island Staten Island yeah you can
sit this out here too if it's easy
totally different totally different
setup so Manhattan um like the buildings
it's all buildings right you know house
to house we used to call it so you would
go like pale to P pale that's maybe on
like 10 blocks like where I was at but
you get like one building on a corner of
just say second and 42nd I mean there's
2,000 bags out there wow and they we
used to call them sausage bags okay so
they have compactors in the buildings
that literally compact these things and
then the guys not the ends and they're
you know anywhere from 3 feet to you
know four or five feet long oh yeah it's
like somebody making um sausage Rings
yeah and they were not like and they
would not like really so you got that
long dog huh MH and could somebody have
put a body in one you think oh yeah you
could have put a body in any one of them
I ain't looking yeah that other dude is
I'm not I could give a damn
yeah that dude I would tell
people all the time the minute you want
to do that just put it in a bag I ain't
looking oh that dude's selling femur on
ETS exactly you know yep price that
dude's out there yeah that dude's out
there slanging Shin Bones on on
eBay but Dam so somebody could put a
body in one of those bags zip it out to
the garbage guy you never know you know
these days everybody's watching you you
Google something you get an ass for it
you know you uh you whisper something to
your cousin next thing you know
they're they you're getting
advertisements for tootsie rolls or
something we're all being monitored it
feels like that's why you need a VPN
with
expressvpn 100% of your traffic is
rerouted through their encrypted servers
so no one can see a thing you can search
for whatever you want you want to um you
want a geot track a Wolverine or a or a
woman across town or a man if you would
love a man you can do it and nobody will
know expressvpn works on all your
devices whether you browse the internet
on your phone tablet computer you can
use up to five devices at the same time
under one
expressvpn
subscription so stop letting people
invade your privacy right now get three
extra months of expressvpn for free when
you go to
expressvpn.com
Theo that's expressvpn.com
EO expressvpn.com SL Theo to learn more
you know you don't know you're a bad
cook until you till you know it you know
I remember one time I heated up a can of
pears and it got so hot I couldn't even
get in the can I burned both of my hands
the front and the back of my
hands um but you got to have good
cookware as well and that's what I'm
here to tell you about today is
hexclad that's right no longer using
your roommates dishes guys hexclad has
revolutionized the cookware industry
with a hybrid pan that gives you all the
convenience and cleanup of nonstick the
versatility of your grandma's cast iron
and they are so durable gosh I mean you
could do a RI eye in it you could do a
dang you could make a wedding cake in it
and they last a lifetime they will
Outlast you they will be in your will
we're serious they have a lifetime
warranty just in case you find a way to
destroy them while you're making your uh
ramen noodles for some stranger you met
on uh social media Gordon Ramsay might
be the toughest critic in the world and
these are the pots and pans that he uses
at home and in his Michelin star
restaurants hex
clad support our show and check them out
at hexclad
dcom Theo that's h eex c a
d SLT H
EO listeners get 10% off their order by
going to that link just go to hexclad
docomo so a way to get a if you want to
get if you decided to decease somebody
or kill somebody I don't like to use
that term but make somebody be dead
immediately in front of you let's say
that uh and in New York City you could
put them into the shoot in your building
the trash Sho well I wouldn't do that
like that's a little much but if you had
you know access to the compactor okay
then I think it's different but if
you're going to shoot a dude 13 flights
down I mean somebody's about to hear you
know there's got to be some blood you
know dink dink dink dink going down
somebody can hear a wrist watch the wall
yeah somebody's watch is going to
connect and something's going to Ping in
and you know how that goes right so if
you could get the body down to the
compactor there's a chance it could just
be thrown out in one of those sausage
bags gone wow yeah and we used to dude
you know you would have cars park so
tight and there's 30 just say in a
smaller stop there's 15 20 30 bags wow d
i be like oh sad day for this Jaguar
owner I would literally cuz I would tell
you know I was 21 I was stupid oh yeah I
would grab them both sides slide them
right across the hood a Jaguar whatever
people dude whatever call that oh bro I
there was nothing better than
doing something to the rich boy
you know well they just didn't care oh
yeah they had no respect for me so now
it's like all right oh CU they parked
illegally they well no they parked
legally but they give you no space so
now those bags you know they're heavy
and I get it everybody would say well we
don't know we're not garbage men right
well now you're going to know yeah now
you now you got to go to the body shop
fix your on your dime yeah dude I
remember when I used to go over to rich
people's houses my buddy Jeff would
steal s he had a whole collection of
silverware and we were poor poor so it
was like everybody was rich you know
what I'm saying we knew people if you
had a front door bro you had a
little bit of money you know so like
Jeff has silverware from
everybody dude and then if I went over
to rich people's houses a lot of times I
would pick my nose when they weren't
looking and feed a booger to
that
dog just to stay in the building
a little huh what was the thought
process of getting out of that I think
for me it was something like
uh start from the bottom like you
convince these animals to work
for you lowkey you know what I'm saying
it was like I'm going to uh they may
think they're doing all this and all
that but who's feeding these
animals Yeah just they just ate your
booger yeah that's what I'm saying no I
get it I mean it was like I'm taking
things to the lowest it's like I'm just
like I don't know it's probably like
some Lord of The Fly or
whatever
yeah so you got the big sausage bags in
the city right yeah and the the city is
just oh it's hell it's multiplied crazy
like there were times where you knew
that like if their compactors were broke
like it was awful man really CU now they
put out so they could probably fit I'd
say a normal four or five bags of
garbage in one of these sausage bags but
now the compactor broke so now they got
to put regular just bags out so it just
went from 10 to 15 sausage bags to 150
regular garbage B and it's one at a time
you know just chucking them over the
cars and like and now do you throw them
to a buddy and he puts him in or you
that's the goal in the city you're
pretty much just working together the
whole time okay when you go to S Island
it's like half hour on half hour off
okay so I'll drive for a half hour you
load for a half hour vice versa back and
forth till the route's done okay but in
Manhattan it's like you know all hands
on deck cuz those bags are kind of heavy
sometimes it reminds me a little like
watching that show
um it's like a ocean show you know what
I'm talking about it's like a ocean show
and they're angry and every year one of
them dies and they put it on like TMZ
but they're looking for carpers they're
looking for uh fish or something
maybe I don't know yeah here's a video
right here of some sanitation guys right
here throwing garbage bags into yep oh
wow that dude huh I was awesome at that
were you
really bro that dude wow uh-huh that's a
private guy that's buddy heeled right
there yep that's a private guy oh that's
a private guy that's not one of your
boys yeah so how can you tell for yeah
the truck all trucks were white okay the
white elephant that's what they called
it and the white elfant always got in
people's way really piss them off oh
yeah you guys are the worst dude I used
to do the whole Hogan real quick yeah I
used to do that I us take my gloves off
and they B you know in Manhattan and I'd
be
like you're an ass hole I'm like you
should have woke up 10 minutes early cuz
now you're stuck behind me and I ain't
moving well the craziest thing about it
about a sanitation truck is that not
only you stuck but it smells bad you
like he and they used to get
real close and and like I was saying
when the used to spray out
especially rainy days after a rainy day
or or if it was raining wet days dude
that thing and the cars would get
covered wow i' be like oh well that's on
you dude so so that must have been kind
of fun just throwing those bags that
seem like something a kid would love to
do I throwing behind my back just
running down the street you know in
Staten Island because it's a lot lighter
in stat Island right right so that was
in Staten Island but in the city it's a
little bit more you got to have your
dude there you guys are loading this
thing up you're just keeping it moving
yeah um and in the city how many bags
can go or those big sausage bags can go
into uh the cycle and what's the cycle
like of the truck well we I mean you
probably fit like five six of those bags
in at a time but your your average in
Manhattan was 10 to 13 14 tons of
garbage in per truck per truck so you
start out with nothing in there empty
okay and uh there's a compactor in the
middle like in the in the truck and then
it just cycles and compacts it the whole
time okay and the rule you got to get
the route so you have to get the whole
route on the truck so you would have to
maneuver sometimes squeeze a little more
squeeze a little more really can you
hear it getting tight back in there
sometimes yeah a hey you could feel it
it changes the whole Drive of the truck
really from being empty to heavy yeah
yeah you know we spoke one time with a
um female truck driver and she had
worked with um and her son I think had
breast reduction surgery but she had
worked with a cement truck right yeah
and she said sometimes when the mixer
was full she would drive and when she
stopped somewhere on the brakes you'd
feel the cement come up the like the
just the back it was just really
interesting so that kind of made me
think of that oh it changes everything
just you know you think about it you
know you double everything cuz tons of
2,000 lbs so 36,000 and then the truck
is probably another 14 you know you're
looking at you know 35 40,000 pounds it
ain't easy to stop wow yeah so you'd
have to set the you yeah you can feel
that weight huh it's pretty crazy yeah
it's harder to stop you know and the
trucks would junk to begin with I think
they New York got like all the
secondhand trucks what they're like oh
try this like Mac Truck like oh yeah try
this I like dude it was
crazy like for me it was terrible I'm
tall I'm 6'5 so it's like just getting
in the truck yeah I had to get so used
to not hitting my knees on the dashboard
it was just not comfortable to sit in so
damn but they didn't care it was
whatever they got a discount on they
took it wow yeah oh that's everybody now
they'll put you in a damn dude they'll
put you in a baby stroller and
make you put six bags on the baby you
know you could fit they're cutting
Corners whatever they can fit three
wheels not four like crazy so how tight
does that trash get in there can you see
it building up like does it build up
some heat is it that yeah no it gets you
know when you dump it you'll see it's
all it's like a brick comes out it'll
start falling out here and there but
there's steam coming off of it methane
gas man yeah yeah yeah and even if you
go out Staten Island has the biggest
landfill in the in the world you could
see it from space oh wow that's landfill
and they have constant pipes that are
burning because all the methane gas
coming out of the ground that's
beautiful man God it's almost like
um yeah like grease or something when
they do the Olympics or whatever and
they light the Torches yeah um oh wow
that is amazing huh yep they stop
dumping it now but that's back they
should have kept dumping yeah they gave
up but it sucks you know because I do
know a lot of people that passed away
and stand out from caner but like that
the cancer rate on Stand Out is awful is
it really that's why I had to get the
hell out of that wow yeah I want to get
into some of that so yeah my friend um
my friend Aaron actually he he's part of
a new company called vespine and what
they do this is pretty interesting
they take the methane gas at landfills
and they burn it and it it but they
converted immediately into electricity
so usable you know yeah that works that
that so now you have electricity that's
right there available so say if they had
like trash trucks or something and that
they were uh electric electric then they
could charge them up immediately or they
could use the energy like for a little
bit they were using it to mine Bitcoin
when Bitcoin was popular but now they're
finding other places to use the energy
but it's just kind of fascinating
something that's going on but I can't
believe that that log is hot huh now
what do they call them bricks logs cuz
that's almost like a damn Diamond of
trash you know yeah it's you know listen
when you dump you just dump you're not
staring at it you just go out and get
out of there you know yeah cuz we used
to dump now in Manhattan we started
dumping on the side of the turnpike in
Jersey and that guy Burns it but he's
got million dooll like filters so he's
able to you know the the smoke coming
out to clean really a come on dude's
crazy money dude you have no idea he was
getting they were charging 50 something
dollar per ton to the city plus he
signed like an $80 million contract with
the city to take all the garbage cuz you
know who got to get paid off to have the
trucks now on the turnpike you know cuz
they don't want that and then he's
selling the ash uhuh just yeah dude just
money over money there's so much money
in garbage dude you have no idea really
it's a billion dollar business damn and
the mafia used to be involved in it
right that's why they were in it well
when you brought up bodies like that's
one thing on stand Island those are the
myths the
tals my step father got rest of his soul
used to work out there he was a tractor
operator and he said the cars used to
come in pimped out Lincoln and they
would just all turn around and the car
used to go up to the top of the hill
never see it again Wow Car just
disappear person disappear they pull out
see you later fellas that was
it it's the devil's ocean baby the
landfill yeah there's a lot of stories
out there with that landfill huh uhhuh I
wonder I wish God would just tell us how
many bodies are in that landfill
sometimes I pray sometimes that I wake
up with a number in my
head because you uh you know there are
definitely did you ever feel like did
you ever get a weird feeling or
premonition like you're driving the
truck home like could there have been a
body in there and you have no idea at
some point whenever that's you're
dumping it you would have seen something
listen you you definitely think you
could get a feeling you know if somebody
comes out and says something you're like
oh maybe this dude just whack somebody
right you know his wife ain't healthy
right now she's probably in this bag
right like I'll throw it in oh yeah but
no I never I had
one these two guys came out of the house
one day hysterical crying oh yeah I'm
like what the happened you know
what now and we were in that kind of
neighborhood in Stan Island and I'm like
all right what's up our dog died I'm
like H oh my gosh bring it get cremated
what the why you telling me they trying
to cut Corners couple gay dudes trying
to cut Corners can we throw it in the
truck I'm like a and I'm a I'm a
dog owner at the time I'm a dog lover
next thing you know with on the bed dude
a yellow lab this thing had to be 100 lb
oh and they both grabbed they were
crying no they it was on the bed they
got rid of the bed the toys the was
still lined up like he was just playing
and then just
dead like and they're like okay K and
just launched him into the back of the
truck I'm like I told my my partner I'm
like dude you got to I can't cycle that
up man yeah like I was like oh so
it's like you would get the feeling if
somebody was like oh yeah can I throw
this bag in like where's your wife yeah
I don't hear you know I heard y'all
fighting last week about garbage and you
know and so what then you tell a guy hey
you pressed the button I ain't pressing
it this yeah I just you know in that
case I was like dude you I told my paa
and he was just he didn't give a
he's like hey all right yeah I like I'll
sell his collar in an hour yeah give a
that big
usable put that on Etsy on uh on
Facebook Marketplace make
$13 they'll sell anything on that
oh yeah dude you could sell your
cousin on that boy you know what
I'm saying if if he can't read if he's
still teachable you know you'll
somebody buy that in an hour on
there you dud you go on there
find your ex-wife on that exactly
you could buy used barettes on there if
you want bro barettes wow that BR that
brought my my Olden age back jez same
man in barettes boy back in the day you
see a girl with a couple barettes in or
I think what it oh you know what girls
used to wear when I was like um in
school they would wear headbands
remember that no my sisters were big in
the scrunchies oh yeah they were all
over the goddamn Place tangled up with
hair all kinds of nasty I grew up with
three sisters so oh really yeah man I
was I was the only boy damn three Three
Sisters you know it I've been through it
wow yeah damn and did you um did any of
them were they okay when you got into
the sanitation game what they say didn't
when he you know oh my sister Abel was
pissed really cuz she filled out the the
and sent it in uhuh and she didn't
get picked to take the test God she was
pissed oh still to this day she reminds
me I got you that job wow that's so well
I took that test that sh was hot as hell
you didn't take it for me she went and
took it and didn't pass it no no no she
didn't get called remember I said oh she
didn't gety only 15 20,000 people took
it wow she didn't get picked to take it
it's crazy that even at the like that
there's a lottery to like there's like
lotteries at every end of the spectrum
everywhere of Life man yep so what time
what what season of the year is the
worst time of the year for trash man
definitely the winters the winters were
awful like the Summers were hot but but
like once you got used to that smell
like even nowadays like it will never
I'll never be able to smell how awful it
is cuz you're just used to it yeah like
it's like second nature yeah you know
the maggot smell and just all that
nastiness it's it's just part of it the
wind is with grueling man really and
that's because of the cold huh just the
cold the ice the you know if it snowed
you're stepping over all that you
still got to pick the garbage up now
you're working 12-hour days with you
know if it snows you're constantly
driving around the truck all done you
know it's it's groing and would you a
lot of cleats and stuff what would you
wear for shoewear just boots wow yeah so
you had you know you had rain boots you
had you know junk boots just for cuz I
always wore like a like a hiking boot
because I can move faster yeah you know
when you're wearing like heavy boots
like they always said Don't wear steel
toes because you know God forbid
something hit you on the foot it'll snap
your toes
off so I don't want oh the steel would
actually snap your toes off yeah so
that's the downside of wearing steel toe
boots if you're in an industry like that
yeah cuz they were awesome cans I mean I
don't think back in the day there used
to be metal cans they used to pick up
Ash in New York city so everybody would
burn that garbage in the buildings and
they would have these like 150 lb steel
garbage cans and I had lifted a few of
them in my time they're no joke man wow
loaded with Ash so they that's what they
used to just dump so the buildings would
just burn their
garbage all the housing buildings they
used to just get rid of the garbage that
way there was no bags on the street so
they had an incinerator in there they
would burn it up every building in New
York had a incinerator wow yep and when
did that change code do you know I don't
one of these people came up with
something that it was killing everybody
so you know oh probably some Monopoly
some one of trump or Chris
Christie's fat buddies I'm sure yeah
they probably on take can you look that
up when that changed yeah they were
probably you know killing the polar
bears or something you know Igloo were
melting somewhere yeah they got a
some grainy video of of a
rare Fox doing two lines of
yeah City ass you know they're
like we can't do this no
more with a
sign stop burning burning your garbage
yeah me yeah how did that fox even learn
to write bro nobody asks any questions
on this anymore here it is in
1989 mayor Ed or coach
cootch wait you know who else talked
about Ed Co cotch I think was uh Bobby
Kennedy Jr when he was on talked about
Ed cotch mayor Ed cotch signed a bill
that required incinerators in New York
City to shut down within four years and
lo and behold all incinerators had
stopped operations by the end of 1993
and that was the end of that no more
trash burning yeah huh does it say why
why any anything else pollution oh the
pollution yeah oh the air pollution yeah
they were just burning right like that
was if you were burning it in your your
fireplace yeah they didn't have like I
was telling you in Jersey this guy has a
multi-million dollar you know filter and
no more missions blah blah blah they
didn't have that back then oh I see you
said every building was burnning but
weren't the trash men just picking it up
and taking it somewhere to burn it no
then it was just ash so they would just
getting rid of it I don't know what they
did with it back then but I mean after
the trash men after they shut down the
incinerators the trashman just took it
oh they just put it in a landfill yeah
so they weren't burning it no so then
that's when there's a few landfills they
started there was one in Brooklyn
there's I I think they were like all
over New York but Staten Island oh yeah
we're just going to do this for a few
years and then it turns into the biggest
landfill like known to me wow and yeah
what do you say to people who like cuz a
lot of landfills have been filled over
with dirt and people buy houses on them
right what do you say to the people who
you know you buy a house and then four
years later you you know everything
you know everything you eat tastes like
Fig Newtons and uh B
baby gravy or something and your son's
got facial hair at 4 you know
yeah that's probably what's going on
they're actually St in Island they're
making into a park uhuh yeah and I mean
dude yeah I've seen animals out there
some Wicked yeah dude I mean dude
there's this this gopher or whatever the
it was dude it looked like a
full-blown piple that's how big this
thing was I swear I saw a bear
out there everybody told me I was crazy
but cuz there was a ton of deal like the
D swim from Jersey they were coming in
why they H it over there no it's just
like anywhere else they're building and
they're pushing them out of their home
so now they see this big Forest across
the and the river qu you know the
whatever the hell it is it's not a river
but there's a short little spurt from
Jersey to Staten Island in one the
location and they just swim over and
they got a whole and nobody can
shoot them yeah you can't you can't uh
shoot that close to the city huh you
just can't hunt on S out what is is
there like a habitat on the landfills is
there like Animalia that's out there
living is there what is that like is it
almost seems like cuz it's almost its
whole own like like Narnia like a
dirt like a oh
definitely you trash Narnia you see
mutant stuff out there really yeah you
know rats look like cats yeah um like I
said there was like a gopher that looked
like a pull um you know you got deer
running through that place nuts like big
boys and nobody can hunt them oh you
can't hunt them
no dude deer people are crazy I deer
people they'll I'm surprised nobody
jumps the fence and gets out there you
know they try really yeah they've tried
but you know they and they have little
security here and there guy killed a big
buck once and he got he lost he actually
got fired was a mechanic yeah he was a
mechanic for the city and got fired he
was out there hunting on the landfill
yeah he killed it and then everybody saw
it cuz you can't hunt it so you seeing
this this Buck walked around like it was
his area oh yeah he would be out in the
middle of the day just walking the
streets you know he didn't give a
yeah he's gangster but but now they also
put a guy you know on the hill to like
keep the population down oh wait so
there's a um there's a person that works
on the landfill yeah that well they pay
a guy who sleeps in a tent on the
landfill that you know takes care of the
deer population damn what are you
serious yep you know Snips tucks Cuts
you know all kinds of things he he uh
they Dart the de does you read um neut
uh what's it called neutralism no well
it's vasectomies and you know all kinds
of so they're doing animal vasectomy out
there on the landfill anything to keep
the population down wow that's beautiful
man yeah and he sits out there in the
cold and what does he do he he darts
them and they fall asleep yep then he
slips over Snips tucks damn huh and it's
a wrap gosh yep
but some get through sometimes that
nut Grinch he just rolls up on
them huh that's unreal bro yeah
man dud sniper deer out in the middle of
the landfill and but that's what
they do God CU like you said they know
they would just run wild that
sperm Dexter that dude's out there
clipping Buck probably selling
it too oh yeah dude yeah oh deer seing
dude I'll I'll get rid
of a quar 40t of my home here oh in
Tennessee anybody will buy that oh
damn wow bro that's incred I didn't know
that that was a job somebody lives in a
tent on a landfill yep and euthanize or
sedates and then vasectomies yeah deer
they have to keep the population down
that's what they do bears are moving
across New York it says right here the
New York uh State Department of
Environmental con conservation is urging
residents to secure food sources that
might attract bears as beay sightings
increase due to the animal search for
high calorie meals after winter
hibernation wow yeah people I just went
to dinner with a couple friends of ours
me and my wife and the and the and she's
going to kill me that I'm saying this
but and the wife's like wait they like
they don't wait for off peak hours and
come over the bridge I'm like you you
can't be serious to think deer are
running over a bridge like to get there
like no you know they see the forest
they they're getting kicked out of their
land and they see it so they swim over
there yeah well we had a guy a m this
guy was a u medium-sized animal
detective he was on and he had um he
said that yeah a lot of times like
animals will just get into your house
because they don't know it's your house
they just their nature is getting
destroyed and so then they just go to
like whatever seems like a place that's
safe you know yeah so sometimes it's
people's attic you know cuz a lot of
people was Finding raccoons and they add
it yep um in a lot of urban areas but uh
what else dude okay so that there's
methane coming off of that trash block
already when the compressors compress it
that much yeah there's definitely a
light smoke coming off of it if you
threw a match in there would it be
flamable maybe I listen I wasn't trying
that you know to me like I said we get
done two hours I could get done be done
back at the garage hanging out you know
shower done if I get covered with any
junk and be done I'm not paying
attention to what comes out of the truck
at that point is there um how big is
that block that comes out of the truck
like show me with your hand like how big
is that block do you know what out of
the garbage truck yeah the one that gets
compressed after it's full and it
compresses It Up full garbage truck a
full garbage truck oh it's you know like
I said you look at 10 tons I want to say
the truck was 14 feet by maybe 8 n ft
tall by the width of a garbage truck
12 the thing's the size his room the
block of garage yeah that's how big the
garbage is you know there when I went to
standown I I was doing six tons and
that's like totally different situation
that's like more just fluffs out but
when you're in Manhattan you're packing
and packing and packing to get that
route yeah that just like you know does
it just come out as like a big do you
get to see the brick at the end yeah no
it's not like a brick where like it's
going to come out as an actual brick and
they pick it up and just like build a
house with it okay you know what I'm
saying it's like it's just falling apart
like as it's coming out okay
um H yeah and then now they ship they
ship out the garbage from New York they
ship it to like Pennsylvania they use it
for landfill okay like you had said like
they fill the swamps and stuff and then
they build on it 10 years later wow and
then the son has a beard at three oh
yeah dude yeah yeah oh when your son's a
mall Sant at 5 years old exactly
you gotta but they don't care n
moneymore yeah well I mean that's one of
the issues they say that uh a lot of
people that's having uh
autism um radation right retardation
people I try to say it differently
because some people get offended but
retardation um all kind of stuff like
that like brain problems for children is
because our our uh water and food supply
is so contaminated you know yeah I
wouldn't doubt it it makes sense but
they they're not going to you know how
they are they're not going to test it if
somebody's making money off of no
they're making money off of all those
unfortunate cases yeah you know so
that's Chuck Schumer right there making
throw that off yeah you know uh is there
Joy happening around the holidays though
is that an exciting time to be out and
about like CU you get to at least be in
this like there's a
romanticization of people being in New
York City around the holidays right and
I know you guys your route runs ran
early there what time did your route run
yeah we started at 6:00 a.m. okay so you
started at 6:00 a.m. so but was it still
fun to be in the holidays around that
time even though it was so cold or it's
just the worst time CU it's winter yeah
no it was still good times you know just
a lot more people on the street even in
those early days you know everybody's
now coming in who you know people want
to see New York City yeah I don't know
why but to me it's just a hole but
yeah you know that's New York for you oh
yeah people will come to stare at a
hole you know I mean they got porn
sites that's based on it um how long
would it take you those routes in the
city how long does it take how long does
a trash route in the city take a garbage
man it all depended on the day the route
you know you're your average was two and
a half three hours oh wow yeah but by
the time you got out there you know you
start at six by the time you get to the
route because now I we were on the west
side we picked up on the east side so
you get out there like 6:30 quarter to 7
start the route right now you got to
drive to Jersey to dump it oh yeah so by
the time you get back to the garage
you're running hustling for to be able
to sit down you know eat lunch for you
know hour and a half and then you go
home okay like it's it's not worth it
now that I look at it I killed my body
for no reason so you get you get there
at 6 you probably leave for work around
five or something yeah I was getting up
5:00 okay getting up at 5: out the door
about 5:20 yeah you had a rush because
Staten Island was a nightmare trying to
get off it you know there's only the one
bridge to get you know the arzano
through Brooklyn to get into uh
Manhattan okay the traffic was awful so
if you weren't at like I used to meet a
few guys at 5:00 at the bridge okay if
you weren't there at 5 you weren't
getting there by 600 and we all take a
ferry or drive drive okay Bet okay so
you get that done so you can get it done
in a couple of hours right you still get
paid you get paid for an eight hour day
yeah yeah you get paid the eight hours
so there was some like cool value in
getting it done quick yeah were you guys
racing ever was it fun exactly we you
know it was always a competition who
could get done faster but like I said I
look back now you know after having back
surgery two shoulder surgeries a knee
surgery you know really yeah it you look
at you just beat yourself up and for
what and does the city pay for those
surgeries yeah I was on you know on
their time so I did both shoulders and
my knee on the job and then a year after
I retired I just had back surgery two
years in June it was two years wow would
you have disc replacement no I actually
they went in I had uh disectomy
disectomy L5 S1 I don't even know wow
LML P that I call it cuz it's just
pulling out of back on I
have five of them and they they they cut
out three so but my disc was still okay
so they kept them dude you'll be a
wrestler by next year soon enough
soon enough coming down I'm getting
shorter and shorter as they go oh you'll
be living at half Mass dude like
somebody died in service son
they're bringing you down soon enough
cold turkey it may be great on
sandwiches but there's a better way to
break your bad habits we're not talking
about some weird mind Voodoo or some
hoodoo some seaner that could happen
from your crazy neighbor we're talking
about our sponsor fume and they look at
the problem in a different way not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad from
your habit fume is an Innovative award
nominated device that does just that
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural instead of vapor fume
uses flavored air and instead of harmful
chemicals fume uses allnatural delicious
flavors you get it instead of bad fume
is good it's a habit you're free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad habit
easy stopping is something we all put
off because it's hard but switching to
fume is easy and even fun fume has
served over 100,000 customers and has
thousands of success stories join fume
in accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to tr fume and
use code Theo to save 10% off when you
get the journey pack that's TR R YF
m.com and use code Theo to save an
additional 10% off your order today
today's episode is brought to you by
better help if you need help if you if
you aren't lined up if you aren't
connecting with yourself if things have
gotten astray you're not the the only
one I take antidepressants right now I'm
I I was in therapy yesterday you know
when you need it you need it and if it's
at time for you that's okay give it a
shot better help that's right they can
match you with a licensed therapist just
fill out a brief questionnaire and you
can switch therapist at any time for no
additional charge if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's convenient
flexible and can suit to your schedule
you can connect with your therapist over
phone uh face time or or uh or even just
text whatever you
need
therapy it's okay that's what I'm
telling you make your brain your friend
with betterhelp visit betterhelp.com
Theo today to get 10% off your first
month that's
betterhelp.com
tho
this episode is sponsored by better hell
wow man so there's a lot of injuries on
the job yeah and like I said we ran
around like idiots like I say to guys
now all of them I still talk to guys on
the job I'm like don't stop running
around don't do this stuff no more like
what do you mean running around when you
say that what like so at at one point I
want to say five six years on they they
cut the steps off the trucks so it was
it was all right you used to jump on the
back of the truck hang on you know I'm
sure you see pictures of guys you know
whipping I mean I had guys that do 50
mph and I'm on the back of the truck
hanging off a deal life oh that's
awesome boom hitting bumps and you know
yeah yeah oh y'all were doing drugs back
there o I wasn't doing drugs I never did
that stuff but there was oh okay you
mean hitting bumps in the truck H bumps
oh not yeah my bad man I and I'm not
trying to accuse you of doing anything
no but listen I'll I I'll get to that
but yeah so you uh you know then they
cut the steps off the truck why to make
it harder for y well pretty much but the
union was saying like
you know we all thought it was because
we were getting to done too fast okay
you know and listen it's reality like if
we're getting done in two three hours
they're saying what are you doing the
rest of the day which is totally
understood being in the union don't you
know what a Union is for you
know and and we would just get be fine
we're just going back and hanging out
eating lunch you know some guys would
you know hang around play cards some
others would you know doing what they
were doing yeah enjoying their lives but
uh but yeah it just wasn't you know to
rush and run around but that's what I
did when I went to standown I was
working with a guy who ran mile like
marathons on weekends wow dude my buddy
Eric like dude we were running like I
did probably three four miles easy every
day running so you're cruising then pull
this mic down just a little lower it
yeah I'm like running like just running
on the side of a truck like just running
house to house CH so we was pretty
athletic at that time yeah when you had
the when the trucks had the three steps
on I was pretty
athletic no when they when they took the
steps off you know oh then you got to
run along yeah then we were running
along you know more guys were getting a
little healthier yeah it's not the most
healthy job really yeah lunch always
lunch always came with like dessert oh
yeah like you know for what you know a
hogy and then add on some donuts oh yeah
coffee get your a little cut of
cheesec cake huhu around the
holidays huh in memory of big
Carlos or whatever
yeah I feel that man damn well that's
like New Orleans I think New Jersey and
New Orleans have always been very
similar uh I think some of like I bet
probably stat some of that accent you
also hear in New Orleans that people
like to have a meal it's
important you know people will have a
beer at lunch a lot of times if they
only have two or children or less you
know you get like a lot of you know it's
part of it's a little bit more cultural
to be eaten you know so you guys would
get done you guys would go eat so you
guys are getting paid for the full day
you got a couple of hours you get done
so you must have been enjoying that yeah
it was good it was sit down time like
you said you're getting paid for the
eight hours but there were guys that
stayed out there all day they didn't
mind it they you know on those hot days
or the cold days they didn't mind it
they stayed out there and do you have to
wear a shirt the whole time or what is
the uh you have people doing shirtless
or not yeah was some guys that wore some
you know questionable stuff oh yeah but
like before I got on like in '96 like
all the rules changed
they went to the federal license like
before that prior you didn't need a CDL
to drive the trucks wait you didn't need
a you didn't need a commercial driver's
license to drive a sanitation trck yep
up until 96 so those guys were partying
damn bro what dude those guys were part
in I heard some stories so you could you
could drive a Ford Escort and then drive
a garbage truck exactly there guys like
a Min coopa they'll come in in a Mini
Cooper and then jump in the garbage
truck I could do this a maximum Cooper
yeah that's insane so yeah then
they went to the federal license so now
it means everybody's got to get drug
tested you know random drug test
everything 96 that started yeah and the
party in here and there some guys just
didn't care so they still went for it
would some guys just drink on the job
was there any partying on the job I had
guys you know one of my best guys you
know got rest of his soul like literally
out the gate 6:00 a.m. Hey kid stop over
here
run into the store come out two tall
boys oh yeah you know then and they did
the routes where every half hour there
was a deli him and his partner so if I
filled in with him for his partner like
literally every time it was a half hour
up there was a different Deli oh so they
got a full of Morella and two beers huh
run in God brother praise God yeah no
guys enjoyed themselves yeah that sounds
nice that sounds like it should be you
know before they started P
everything in America's penny pinching
Fiasco now nobody can have a
cheek full of strong cheese and
two
uh Bush lights you know just to
get through the work day H you know
there was one dude that dude he was
purple at one point well what happened
to him he was just drinking oh drinking
that much dude his skin was it was awful
some people I don't even know if he's
alive anymore he's not I'll tell you
it's that guy ain't Al liive dude look
after purple it just you turn
into a BLM activist a rap after
that right right in the ground oh man
that's and what about was a lot of
uppers cuz it seems like people would be
on Aderall people would be on uh cocaine
you know people would be po you know
like was there anybody that could do
that kind of Lifestyle oh there were
guys that party like that yeah you know
there was one guy like right out of the
70s my first day in Stand now so let's
talk about this day like the other one
not as bad this guy said like bandana on
7s glasses right out of hippie Central
right yeah oh you're with me I'm like
all right cool now I'm in Staten Island
first day I'm like what the hell's going
on here once again they don't know who I
am so they shove you with this guy he's
like all right kid you go up and drive
first I'll stay in the back so I'm like
all right so I'm driving a route I don't
I live in standown still didn't know
streets wow you know so I'm just driving
around yeah and I'm like what's that
smell dude's hanging on the back living
his dream just toking away getting high
H and then like half hour go by all
right kid now you go out I'll let you
know when I'm ready wow I'm still SM I'm
like but some guys did it and it was a
daily thing pull up a picture of Stevie
Starlight if you can see if this this
guy looks anything like this gentleman
or not but some guys just couldn't
couldn't stop man look like this guy a
little
maybe
yeah no not that crazy of hair yeah
Steve is like like B down across his
head oh yeah yeah yeah you know I know
what you're talking about like circle
glasses yeah yeah huh some guy who's
uh he listens to Springsteen but
he don't admit it huh yeah probably in
the closet yeah yeah closet Springsteen
definitely not telling people about it
you know um yeah once you get into
Staten Island what things changing
because it's more like family housing
and stuff right exactly and what is that
like does it almost feel like a lot
easier does it not feel like the front
lines of trash cuz I feel like in the
City you're on the front lines
you're right there it's coming out of
the shoot you're you know you
got guys catching in their beard
and but out in the out in the in
the suburbs it feels like it would be a
little bit easier is it or not and the
listen when you get to the suburbs now
it turns into now you're dealing with
homeowners like when you were in the
buildings you were in the buildings you
had you didn't they didn't care yeah you
never saw them you know never saw people
it's not like hey I'm I'm from or F yeah
you know you're an idiot like they you
know they don't care Oh in a city you
could just drive and just yell anyway
time yeah yeah there's cabs beeping like
so you never you know you're not waking
anybody up everybody's used to it right
and you come to s island and you know
even Queens areas like Brooklyn areas
now you're waking everybody up it's 6:00
a.m. so who's bitching about that um
like I said getting in the way yeah like
there's certain areas that we couldn't
go in like they make them pick up mid
night to like 5 so that you're not in
their way really so like what do you
mean richer areas no just owned areas by
certain types of people in okay so New
York so maybe upper echelon types or
whatever you think no certain religion
people okay they have their so like the
Orthodox Jews don't want you in their
neighborhood between 12 to five Bingo
wow and those are some nasty mother is
it pretty nasty over there in their
neighborhood well they just listen it's
nothing against them cuz I have actually
been in some of those houses yeah cuz
they are there are people in those areas
that are very nice but then you know
Passover comes and they throw everything
out they're like five six year olds
throwing matches like lighting
on fire it was crazy I was like I can't
do this no more cuz they would bring
everybody pretty much who was available
from other garages to come and do this
and you get one truck on a block and you
just go up and down all day and they
throw everything out like I didn't know
if you knew that about the Orthodox Jews
uh they just get rid of everything
they throw everything out couches beds
clothes everything goes in garbage why
it's just part of the tradition part of
their religion wow star
fresh it's it's dude it's crazy so you
got tons of trash yeah and it's just
more of it's just chaos so like it would
be a garbage truck every block and a and
a fire truck fireman would have like
three blocks because the kids running
around like and I had guys do it plenty
of times they light something on fire
and then throw in the back of the truck
now if I don't see it now everything in
the truck's on fire why do they do that
is that like a kind of like a just a are
they training for like battle or
something no it's just the kids oh kids
screwing around animals oh yeah oh I
blocked a a bus one day and then that's
what I'm saying like then that's when
they get into we don't want them on the
truck uh the streets early this time
blah blah blah and these little kids get
off the buses cuz now I held them up on
the Block and they're blowing the horn
you know they have their own police
their own people and they tell you you
got to move the truck I'm like dude I'm
almost done with the block I'm not
moving the truck yeah the little kid
gets off and he's flicking me the finger
wow he's like five I'm like what do they
respect huh what goes on here I don't
know I got a bunch of Jewish friends I
don't any Orthodox us friends though
them OJs I think or whatever you know I
don't yeah I don't know I shared a room
at a I shared I didn't I sh I was in a
halfway house with a Orthodox dude one
time and he brought his own grp
he was dressed like Biggie Smalls at a
masonic temple and he was sweating and
if you said around him he'd
he couldn't e his eyes oh he'd
open his mouth and put his
tongue out his guy was a perv and uh he
was grilling his own Meats in his
room or whatever with the
sunlight or whatever I don't know what
the dude the guy with have bait you know
he's in there making burn ends
or whatever at 4:00 a.m. you
know when when I say he can it was just
with magnifying glass yeah the was
unre a cloud comes he's like
damn it they ruined again and it was
Arizona dude this day he showed up on
the porch literally I'm not joking it
was 104 degrees outside and this guy is
dressed bro like cruel DeVille bro this
they wear some gear oh this
guy had been raising some mixed
dogs in his coat bro this guy he smelled
horrible um what yeah What ethnicity
probably has the worst smelling garbage
would it be Orthodox you think
no it was all the same it was all it's
garbage man once you throw it in there
it's all Blended in and like you said
during the Summers it was it was
grueling like people would walk by like
covering their faces like that's how bad
the truck melt sometimes I once you're
in it you don't know anymore you you
don't smell nothing anymore you get used
to it huh so used to it cat cat YN was
the worst for me oh it was awful cuz it
would you would rub up on a bag that a
cat just pissed on and like yeah like
you were saying with the truck now we we
get in me and my partner and I I know
like bag stayed far away from me yeah
you know I'm big enough guy long enough
arms I kept that away never let the
bags touch my legs and I would look at
my Pawn I'm like you got hit and he's
like what do you mean I said you don't
smell that cuz now you get in it's even
cold out you close the doors put their
heat on and you smell that turn cat piss
up you know oh yeah oh yeah disgusting
it's the worst smell out there yeah I
remember we used to get a bowl of cat
passing uh we would do a hair dryer over
it bro just to piss my sister
off do it under the door by her room
her dude awful her um wow so
there's no time a year really when the
trash smells worse huh well the Summer's
a bit just the Summer's overall but yeah
it's you know there was some point you
know you would open up a lid and if it
was sitting there with maggots and stuff
you you get a kick MH and that's another
smell that was pretty brutal MH but
other than that it's you got used to it
was there a burrow of New York where the
trash smelled the worst do you think no
okay all the same stand is there was a
movie theater not far from the dump
before they closed it it was awful to
smell and they were building houses like
crazy right there I'm like how could
people buy and then I became a garbage
man and like then I don't smell it no
more stand out don't smell no more cuzz
we would get you know on all the
Time by Le buros yeah uh you know trash
island you know all that but you just
didn't smell it dude there's a lot of
Pride for people that live on trash I
think you know there's something almost
something pretty amazing about
it in a weird way like I when I was
growing up we would burn a trash in a
ditch that was the big thing in our area
you know you bring everything out you
burn it in a ditch the kids we would
like get wet like get hose each other
down and then run through the smoke till
you look all black you know you'd be out
there like a you know know that's
different it would be like yeah you know
you would just it wasn't like doing
blackfacing it was just like burning
trash and but you definitely looked a
little Smokey by the end you know it was
it was just something to do you know
yeah um what were we talking about
oh I don't know when I went out to
stal oh yeah and what got difference
yeah it it's just like I said you you
deal with a different person now pick
yeah you're well you're dealing with
people who own
the garbage like it's their house house
to house to house to house I tell people
all the time I knew things about you
from your garbage that you do not think
I know really and then I wasn't picking
through it right you know when you put
that stuff in it breaks up the bags I
knew when people it you know it was your
wife's time of the month I know my wife
will be disgusted by that but you knew
it you know it when the bag's ripped
your life is in front of me and I ain't
picking through it right but I but yeah
but you and it's crazy how quick you see
things so fast dude I did this game one
day and I went in New York City right
downtown I went in the city like I think
I was on the Lower East
Side and I did this game with people I
said I'mma open a bag of trash you smell
it you take a whiff out of it right just
a random bag okay and if you can guess
three items that are in it I give you a
hundred bucks right so dude so these
people they all thought I was like that
the bags I had like brought them from
home or something and put them together
whatever I was picking these up
from the corner so you didn't
even know if they would be right bro I
had no idea what was in them dude so we
had people we cracking back and
people are taking hits off of it dude
over there off of an alphabet City bro
that was nasty stuff down there yeah
there's a we made a video of it online
but um anyway that was something we did
with trash in the city um what about the
was there any ladies that tried to flirt
with you that ever happened on the route
once you got into into the houses like
any B babies or any they
didn't notice you trying to run that can
clam out on you bro well that's why I
wore the
shirt my but this shirt's 25 years old
really it's been I was going to give it
to you but it says put out your can here
comes the garbage man I used to sport
this shirt all the time and it's a sexy
lady huh with her butt out you know with
her ass hanging in in the wind I like
that but no listen you didn't you didn't
see people yeah unless you were you know
waking people up and and you know in
their way other than that they you were
not like it it was crazy because nobody
even knew they never acknowledged you
wow New York hated you because you were
loud until I don't remember the year but
like the New York Post or Daily News one
of those papers in New York they
posted how much money we made per year
mhm that was it now everybody wanted the
job yeah when you when they see you're
making six figures picking garbage up oh
well I my guy this list and now all of a
sudden they know you're you're around
wow once the money comes on huh but
prior to that they could care less
that's that same thing happened with Joe
Rogan in a way I think once he got a
Spotify deal and people saw like oh he's
making money they all jump on his tracks
now they all want to write
articles about him say he's racist
they're just using his name you know
yeah exactly so you guys pull in six
figures a year with the job yeah right
starting first year it gains traction no
yeah my first year I think if I had to
guess 27 Grand wow but but just with the
overtime with the winter with the snow
and all that stuff with you know I think
my first year I made like almost 60 wow
okay so it almost doubled right because
you have to be there you know New York
doesn't stop so it's you're on call all
day you know 12 hour shifts I've worked
up to 31 day straight 12- hour shifts oh
you know 31 you know inches of snow here
2 feet of snow here it happens so but
you can make that money I just had a guy
just retired he was making almost 200
Grand wow picking garbage of but he
would do 12h hour days every day over
time he would eat up you know kind of
hated his family so yeah you know and
you get it when you meet these families
you're like yeah this is why this guy
works all the time yeah
wow um yeah this says G bottom 20% 36.3
this must be old though no it's it's I
think starting right now is like 70 okay
the average salary for a garbage
collector in New York is around $76,000
per year and that's not overtime right
so that's not having your overtime so
that's where you can get up to 100 you
can get six figures wow almost double
that easy wow guys were doubling it easy
remember when they had the fad of like
the kids meet the garbage man oh I love
yeah that was like when we were growing
up yeah I used to you know love throwing
beers to the guys yeah and it turned out
like then I come to stand now and those
guys were still on on the job nuh I was
like dude I remember you you don't he
was like yeah you were that fat little
kid thr off the top of the cuz I
still lived on the same block uhh so
they kind of were like yeah you had a we
had like a porch out front and you know
we I dro the beers down to the guys yeah
but like I was saying with wearing like
they didn't wear uniforms back then D
had like a wife beater on and like a
pair of shorts oh yeah just gaggling
through the streets like give a
yeah dudes wearing a snorkel and
a exactly
yeah some questionable stuff back then
dude wearing a snorkel in a bathrobe
over there
but like you said they like I was saying
they didn't acknowledge you yeah you
were there you pick the garbage up you
left you're kind of the Invisible Man
exactly you really are because yeah
nobody wants to get that close people
kind of want to pretend you don't exist
unless you're making noise people don't
engage yeah
you yeah you're kind of the Invisible
Man until they realize you were making
money and then Sun like oh look at this
Rich rolling through here gu I
got to put more garbage out yeah yeah
you know and then they would turn into
well it's your job you know pick this up
here take this you have to take this
yeah what's the worst part to the job
that you get that kind of stuff is
people telling you like yeah just being
they always tell you oh yeah you know I
pay your salary so I we always used to
keep like nickels and dimes in the truck
and I'd be like hold on I'll give you
your money back because they would
always say like all right each person
gives you a nickel a year or and I would
throw the nickel at them here here's
your money the out of my face you
got to take this the guy's whole
apartment out there yeah it's like dude
go no and I would always respect the
person to come out if you just said
Thank you or even gave us water cuz you
know you weren't supposed to take money
and all that stuff if you just said
Thank you and acknowledge me like I said
that we were you know everybody nobody
knew us thank you went a long way with
me I take everything I don't care you
know but when you look at me like oh I
pay your salary and look down to me yeah
yeah go yourself yeah agreed your
stuff would stay there for months oh
yeah I put it back in your
house yeah I'll throw it right back on
your
curve dude I'll take it this is how
spiteful I would have been bro I would
have picked it up and the next day
brought it back put it
back on the guy's door step I got rid of
this yesterday where' this come back
make him think he's crazy bro um now
what about what's that you had that a
lot you know people were very you know
people thought they owned you yep yeah I
pay your salary and all that junk so
you that's what I say to that bro
them yeah I think we always have
respect for people that did something
you know well we lived also we got a
little rural by us so sometimes you'd
have the the bootleg garbage man you
know who started their own service a guy
who put like a took a truck and just put
Three Wooden uh plywood walls on you
know what I'm talking about make the
back of the truck a little taller fit
more bags just load it up BR that dude
with uh our neighbor was one of
those guys for a while so his truck
would always be out there but uh he go
to the rural routes you know and get him
a little bit of garbage man well cuz we
used to take everything you know you're
talking you know couches beds you know
everything even with recycling you're
taking refrigerators and all that stuff
really everything we took everything
until What year no still to this day we
had you had to take everything so you'll
throw a refrigerator in the back of a
garbage truck yeah well our recycling
trucks they went to two sides oh for
recycling it's so annoying yeah but
there was some that didn't fit in the
small side you know with the recycling
trucks now that theity he gets so now
yeah it would call you up be like oh you
got to go and throw it in the in the
regular garbage truck wow so a recycling
truck is a different truck different
truck it's split down the middle there's
like a say 28 in side on this side and a
threefoot side on the other side okay so
the truck is split into two so you could
pick up paper and you could pick up
metal glass you know any stove stuff
like that you put on the other side on
the metal on the yeah on the metal side
okay wow and how do you decipher that
cuz a lot of times people just put a
recycling bin a big a recycling garbage
can out there right got to be separated
in New York but I didn't give a
right we used to drive early days we
used to open the sides of the truck
there's a door so you could the
mechanics and stuff can get in there and
work on the compactor and stuff so we
used to bring the blades all the way
home open the side hatch and drive the
streets and while I was driving you were
in the back loading but I was throwing
stuff in the side of the truck while you
were in the back so we were just loading
the whole truck the whole the
whole block with whatever just I didn't
care I just threw it all in yeah it all
winds up in the same place does it a
good amount of it the paper is recycled
100% everybody gets crazy with the you
know the bottles and the glass and all
that unfortunately I tell people the
truth and they didn't never wanted to
hear it cans and stuff yes metal they
recycle the bottles they just break up
and winds up in a landfill wow colored
glass was like gold to them really and
they stopped using it for everything
glass is cheaper to make than it is to
rec recycle and all that it's too
expensive so colored glass what do you
mean why was colored glass AV valuable
just cuz now you you had to pigment it
and and put color into it the regular
glass so it cost more to make so like if
you got you know like a green glass it
already has the color in it so they melt
it down and they use it again oh but
they stopped using all that like all the
beer bottles and stuff they they really
don't use that I remember Sprite used to
come in like a green bottle yep no more
that was crazy bro you got your the
Sprite bro now they're jamming
you all up you think it's Sprite Zero
now oh yeah yeah Sprite Zero dude come
out the closet bro I'm want full Sprite
give me full no caffeine yeah I want
yeah I want pure sugar bro um what
did were there some accidents with the
trucks how dangerous did it get for
people cuz if people didn't have
commercial driver's license and they're
driving those trucks in the beginning
was there a lot of like uh was there
casualties was there yeah guys would do
there were a few guys that passed away
um you know and it was more just
people's stupidity you know I had one
guy I don't know why he was holding
something going in the truck while up
ripping his armal the trucki it pulled
him in dude literally next time I saw
him he had like this mechanical like
three finger metal thing oh like a skill
crane yeah he was like what he was like
picking up like teddy bears and get
you a care bear I'm like dude
what are you doing well my hand got
stuck he said his hand got stuck and
sucked him in and it literally just his
arm off yeah
is that a is that a blade right there
wow yeah dude I had another guy was
holding paper in New York that would
wrap the bundles of paper before all
this technology came out now he used to
pick massive bundles up and he had the
paper in the back of the truck and
literally almost slid off all his
fingers cuz his fingers were caught in
the string and when the the truck closed
it tighten the string up so much dude
like looked like a ring got caught on
all four of his oh it was nasty they
surgically fix his fingers like it was
the nightmare wow so there's some
dangerous ends to it trash collector
dies after inhaling discarded
acid yeah no that's a guy uh I think
that's the St Island
guy let's see what happened New York
City Sanitation worker died yesterday
after he inhaled the fumes of a
corrosive acid from a discarded
container that burst under the
compacting blades of a garbage truck
making routine collections in Brooklyn
it might have been he I think might be
the last name let's see the source of
the acid was not known as of last night
when this article was written this is in
uh uh I think 2006 touch off a second
sanitation worker was injured in the
incident which brought the mayor and
sanitation commissioner rushing to the
burn unit of New York Hospital touched
off uh the Brooklyn dist Attorney office
said the investigation is continuing
depending on what evidence is obtained
anything else wow yeah cuz somebody
threw a battery a car battery like in a
bag like I said you don't know what's in
there and when when it cycled it
exploded all over the dude and that
sh'll kill you instantly like yeah it
was it was shitty I think I want to say
his last name was Heeney but I could be
wrong I wasn't on the job yet so I
didn't know yeah but Hanley Hanley
that's it
wow yeah what is there other some other
injuries like what about people ever hit
pedestrians with trucks and stuff yeah
that you know list I stayed away from
all that but they were definitely guys
that did not were not good drivers they
clipp
they CIT people's toes and and hand
I used to yell watch your toes cuz
people in watch your toes that's what
you're yelling yeah because you know on
the corners of Manhattan you know
everybody standing in the
sidewalk like standing in the crosswalk
it's like dude watch your toes damn yeah
there a guy there was a guy in New York
I want to say it was Manhattan a dude
just rolled and it was his partner just
rolled right over his feet blew they
blow it blows out your ankle uh-uh yeah
when they rolled right over his foot
his ankle blew out because of the
pressure yeah the weight of the
truck oh my gosh that's like a cartoon
it's nasty nasty wow I had a buddy
fall out of the truck he was part he was
having fun in the truck let's put it
this way older guy and just dude made a
left and he rolled out his leg went
under I mean they grafted his foot they
grafted everything they saved it but it
looked like he was wearing a moon boot
oh yeah you know got off the job but
anytime I saw him after
that it's like four times the size some
Neil Armstrong fan huh dragging a
marshmallow around it's crazy yeah my
dad had this buddy and uh one of his
feet you know you used to see this
commonly back in the day somebody would
have that big
uh uh soul on their shoe you know
somebody be uneven you know yep and my
buddy had his friend and he would his
friend would always stand on this little
piece of cement because it made him even
bro he like wouldn't leave it in
the neighborhood bro my dad's
neighborhood you know he'd like kind of
walk around it like pivot around it but
he would he leave that a second
he left off that bro yeah the
world got kind of uh everything turned
into a teer totter
for oh wow so that's it's really really
fascinating I'm trying to think of some
other yeah ding you had Mike Row on and
he you know he was one of the guys that
years ago listed the sanitation as like
one of the 10 dead jars is you know wow
and it's just more dude you'd be shocked
at how many people don't see the truck
that literally just drive into the back
of the truck and if you're back there
you know it's a wrap you know there was
a lot of close so there's a lot of
danger that happens like that people
just hit in the back of the truck the
guy standing back there driving not
paying attention to you oh it's
craziness you know everybody's in a rush
yeah especially in New York they just
and you're no pay no mind list so
they're just driving around I mean the
truck can't get any bigger for you not
to to see and they people drive into the
back of the truck all the time damn I
had a dude hit me once literally I see
him in the I'm at break and I see him
bouncing off cars coming down the road
and I'm like what what's this dude doing
like ping ping ping I jumped over like
in the truck there's like this cab like
this little thing where the engine is I
literally was jumping onto my partner
and he was like what what's going on
here like he thought we were getting
frisky at 8: in the morning next thing
you know
Boom the dude D drills the truck
literally drives right into the driver's
side like gas tank right near my like
I'm like what the hell turned out the
dude old dude was on all kinds of
medication oh
yeah so yeah dude my dad sometimes would
let he would go he'd like get into the
PO he'd go to the post office right my
dad was real old when I was born he was
and so uh at 80 years old he's taking me
on rides like I'm going to go to the
Post Office and I think he didn't know
kind of like how age or worked or
whatever cuz I hit like a grow spur and
he's like will you just drive around I
can't legally park here will you drive
around the block for me and I was
10 years old dude you know I was
about five I think I was 53 or something
I'd hit a little grow spurt and his
vision was bad and so I'm next
thing you know I'm driving this Delta 88
bro right this big boat no power
steering bro I go around the
block dude and I don't know how big the
block is you know I go around
hit seven cars bro and this thing was a
piece of dude like a battleship oh
my dad he bed off a couple brothers and
it had some uh 22s in the back right
around the corner so he was always
listening to like NPR like with bass and
like it none of the the whole life
didn't make any sense dude I hit
six cars I finally get back
around to pick up my dad he had no idea
the whole car piece of no
no idea bro god um
what about the rat problem is that a
what what kind of Animalia do y'all run
into on a garbage route bro and be
honest with me yeah no uh just different
areas had different you know stand
Island was like mice you know you'd see
some you know decent size you know like
seven inch 8 inch rats with like you
know a nice siiz tail but that's what
I'm talking about dude a mice is
just a gay rat I think yeah they're just
babies yeah I'm just running around like
idiots I used to squish them with my
feet really could step right on them
yeah they're in the bags and when they
come out you just and they and
eyes popping out all over oh yeah it's
nasty but I stopped doing that when I
got a little older yeah yeah I think you
grow out of that and the government will
put lipstick on him and then
kill him with uh OIC or whatever
so who the know you know I'm saying
like you're the bad guy exactly I
stepped on a few M oh well kill me now
now what about the rat problem in the
city you hear about it you know they
allegedly of Zar to got some uh this
lesbian cheese Hunter up there now
trying to kill him right which
is fine more power to her if she wants
to show up and go to war I'm
game right uh but how bad was the rat
problem in the city well even with that
like let's be honest you ain't getting
rid of them there's no way yeah and
there there was some big boys up there
yeah the UN o cuz you're right near
the water there oh I saw one wearing a
Charles Barkley jersey dude I wouldn't
doubt it up there I was so there's one
night we're working picking baskets up
you know how there's Corner baskets in
uh Manhattan so it's just a basket on
every corner where people throw litter
and stuff you know oh yeah so they all
lined up in in front of the UN so we're
doing the baskets it was early in my
career and is each basket a different
country or something no no it's just a
basket like all along the UN there's
just more there because they don't want
litter okay so there's just more baskets
in the front of the Epcot Center of
trash or something you know so but it's
the Epcot Center of rats I mean dude I'm
talking boys yeah and dude one I dumped
the basket so it was quick like once you
started doing the baskets you spin off
the truck quick Bing bam you're right
back like literally Tak me 30 3 seconds
to dump a pale oh so you throw it dump
it and you're back it's back and boom
and then you jump on the truck you still
had the steps at the time so I see
fluttering going on and dude I mean with
the tail this thing had to be 18 in oh
yeah that probably went to ruers bro
yeah yeah he was that fullback so big
boy
so dude I'm working with this dude I'm
jump off the truck and he dude I'm
running along the truck away from it
dude I'm just running he's like what are
you doing he looks next to me I'm
running I said there's something in
there man he's like what are you mean so
we went back there with like the broom
in the shovel to like kill it and just
cycled it up I was like I ain't
around with it wow cuz you would have
like possums and stuff like as you cycle
it like a little garbage will fall down
and it gives them a little Escape so
they pop out the little mice used to do
that all the time no what now explain it
to me I'm not understanding it so when
you when the cycle goes up in a truck
like sometimes there's like bags and
stuff right at the edge that you just
pushed up right so when you open it
again to now like bring the next set of
garbage up like you would literally get
like a bag or two will flip down and
it'll push garbage up towards the Le
like the ledge of the truck and an
animal that's like their Escape Route
now oh I see so I'm like that I
ain't doing that so I told him you go
back there and he time on a job so he
was used to it he was used to it so
sometimes the the the it'll be cycling
you'll see an animal just pop out of
there yeah you know you get possums rack
Coons uh the mice the rats they
literally just jump right out yeah now
what's the most gang here here's a one
right here garbage man saves kittens
from trash Jesus yeah I mean shaa toade
probably doing this you be shocked man
yeah anybody ever try to put a baby in
the garbage
bro so I won't tell anybody if you no no
no and I know if you're lying too all
right so I had like a year on a job got
hurt I had this uh shoulder done surgery
so they do like this mail carrying thing
where you bring go you know the mail to
like like Lower East garages so you go
to like the main area pick up all the
mail you give it to the each garage so I
pull into one of the garages I forget
somewhere in Manhattan 2 I think oh so
it's a job you can still work even
though you're injured exactly so you I'm
like in rehab know coming back you know
trying to get my arm back together and
next thing you know I walk in the garage
everybody's in tyvec suits white tyvec
you know covered head to toe I'm I got a
T-shirt and pants on I'm like what the
going on here Fu this a Shriner
meeting right so there's a garbage truck
emptied out on the floor cuz they got a
phone call that a girl put a baby in a
corner basket
oh I I just I don't even know if they
found it I just you know nobody puts
baby in a corner basket no no nobody but
they did it listen that they were
nervous you know and that's what they do
these
kids yeah man that's heartbreaking man
what about this video right here garbage
man saves kittens from trash let's get a
little volume on
it this dude cutting in a little
uh look like he cutting open a bag of
coke huh this
guy who
oh he heard
something oh it's a a ball of cats bro
damn baby kittens they heard
the meowing
oh
gosh that's people for you
man
oh that's man that's unreal that's
people yeah yeah what do you learn about
Society what are some of your thoughts
on society you think that like does it
give you a negative look at Society does
you just think this or does it does that
kind of thing even happen like as you
work in that
industry yeah listen it'll change your
mind real quick to just there strange
people out there man it's some crazy
that you see in the
garage like that reminds me of the time
I smell a skunk I'm like what the
is that smell in the back of the truck
like that's something odd so now I could
smell it
and there was like a skunk in like a
little path mark bag like that we used
to call them like the little plastic
bags tied up and everything and I'm
thinking to myself like who the
took the time to grab this skunk kill it
and then put it in a bag yeah it's like
what people ain't right to even think of
doing that like who's playing with
skunks
like perverts bro perverts I
think I wouldn't do it bro yeah people
get rid of any liot yeah like uh I'm
trying to think of the biggest animal
somebody could get rid of without you
guys
noticing probably black lab
huh that was the yellow lab that's dude
I still to this day I could see those
guys crying huh crying and were they gay
guys you
think yeah some would say yeah and no
judgment anyway bro
everybody yeah everybody's got a gay
cousin or son or father you know these
days you can't even
everywhere in three generations
everybody's going to be just gay doing
Uber reats dipping their toes into it oh
yeah who knows
bro um what about on the home front what
is the home front life like for a
sanitation worker is it tough on like
your home life is it easy on it what
kind of life is it the winters were
tough like I said the you know if it
snowed uh you were stuck there 12 12
hour shifts 10 hour shifts like when you
say stuck there what do you mean oh
because it takes so long to get through
the route no it's just like if it snows
like we so New York like and I've been
to here I've been here when they had
that ice storm I think it was a few
years back the whole s like everybody
shuts down New York don't stop like
we're we're out there all night through
the night 12- hour shifts spreading salt
plowing snow I mean oh so you guys do
other jobs instead of just the garbage
oh okay I didn't know this we clean all
the streets the snow we do the salt
spread and the the um the front and
loader work we do all that stuff really
yeah God damn you I guess if the
Rangers needed a Zamboni driver they
could put one of you guys in prob pull
it off wow yeah but I didn't know that
you guys do all those other jobs yeah oh
there's probably if I had to guess over
a hundred different job titles on that
job it's just not garbage man right
there's so many ranking like you you
could have a des job you could have the
guy who hooked me up with this you know
Johnny Lex that that was my boy he had
the desk job you know and that's what
that's a job now what's the desk job
like what's that guy doing nothing he
literally is just setting up the days
you know what's what's tomorrow all
right let me get all the cards in the
routes ready for tomorrow pretty much
nothing yeah it's a you know we call
them tit jobs yeah it's a tit job yeah
so Dar in there just doing fantasy
football really yeah and he's terrible
at it is he yeah he's 0 and six this
terrible I was talking to him last night
I was talking to him last night on my
your team's sad bro he probably had
Aaron Rogers that's why he probably had
an injury yeah know I don't think he did
but just sad but there's there was a lot
of and that winter aspect is a totally
different animal cuz you're doing just
say you know three four days you could
get six inches of snow take you two
three days to like settle in now you got
to go pick all the garbage up that was
left out for the last three four days
mhm so now every house that you normally
do two days a week now it's all double
garbage for one pickup because they cuz
you missed one well yeah and there of
the snow exactly like Manhattan after a
snowstorm o bad news man really piles
and piles of it of garbage garbage just
unlimited garbage it's it's unbelievable
you ever find somebody hiding in the
garbage like do you have to like you
have to you have to hit a b like hit a a
dumpster with a you know wrench
or something to get a homeless guy out
of there ever no I never had to do that
it's pretty you know nobody wants to be
in the garbage in New York wow it's just
it's funny cuz in movies and stuff you
always see this romanticized look of a
homeless guy popping out of a dumpster
you know what I'm saying like that old
kind of well they're around you know but
we don't do container work oh you don't
that's privates the private guys those
containers on the street where those
guys are sleeping behind M yeah no
that's all private what about like a
dumpster at a school or something like
that's private yeah I didn't do that but
that's a whole different truck those are
easy packs so they have Forks on the
front that lift it over the truck and
then compacted and behind them so you
never worked with that I never picked
that up I drove them I used to have to
dump them but I never actually picked
them up so that's called an easy pack
truck the ones that have the forks on
the back that like on the front oh yeah
that go right into those two slots on
the side of the dumpster and then they
throw it back over the top yep and
whenever you throw that back over so
sometimes just a party of trash come
right down the front of juice they're
filthy trucks oh
disgusting
disgusting sometimes the container come
off and be hanging out the side of it
now you got to get somebody out drag it
off it's a nightmare wow yeah um
and then the other truck the truck you
drove more had a cycler in the back that
was just you throw them in yep wow bag
fed or something what do they call it
exactly yeah it's like hand fed you just
bag in and then when it gets full you
can't fit no more you bring it down it
swoops it into the truck compacts it and
then you fill it again and rinse and
repeat how has the how has the industry
changed over the time well now they
actually just put out uh the city I
think this week that they're trying to
bring out where
homeowners I guess if you associations
like if you have a bunch of people cuz
there are certain areas that were loaded
with mice and rats because they were
just you know near swamps and stuff like
that yeah and house to house you you go
to grab a pale and they're scattering
yeah so now they're trying to put these
D little dumpsters but PL
not the metal ones you see at like you
know the restaurants and stuff around
town and now they have things on the
back to lift it you know and my buddy
just said New York just came out with
them you know and it's just it's never
going to work right you know Bloomberg
tried to go to um the arm the arm that
lifts it on its own and one guy's in the
truck and never gets out never touches
anything I have that in New Jersey now
at my house there's just not enough
space there's too many people in New
York right so like there's cars on top
of cars right so there's no room for the
garbage truck to get to the garbage
right there's no room for the arm to get
to the trash exactly right homeowners
across the five burs will soon have to
Shell out at least $50 for new trash
bins as the Big Apple tries to crack
down on rodents by standardizing garbage
collections under new rules announced by
mayor mayor Eric Adams Wednesday single
family homes and small apartment
buildings up to 10 units will have to
purchase the new cans from an as yet
under undetermined vendor in an effort
to modernize the way the big collects
it's trash
wow somebody's biding on that contract a
bet huh money money money it's
crazy how much money there is in garbage
oh nobody thinks of it nope because
you're forgotten nobody realizes it but
to like that like somebody's going to
make those pales now yeah 90% of the
time it's guys that were retired big
Chiefs that are on from the job they go
out and start these businesses because
they had the bright idea when they were
on the job but they said let me bring it
out when I retire right and then oh I
know let's bring it in damn I mean they
do well um not do the uh they pick up
deric Vehicles M sanitation does that
too oh they do yeah any Vehicles that'll
you know the foreman have to go out tag
them you know write whatever date if the
car's not gone off the street with like
no plates and stuff on the stre yeah
definitely they send tow trucks out they
take them too have you ever had to be
involved in that no I didn't deal with
that but you've had involved with
salting the roads orever anything
salting the roads uh front and load is
uh big like rubber TI machines used to
have to fill the spreaders and then I
would have to drive down certain blocks
where you couldn't get like like bigger
spreaders I would have to do dead ends
with that so you like take a bucket back
up a street take a bucket back up pile
it up back there like in the bad storms
you would get like a dump truck with you
and you would load the dump truck and
then they would like dump it all
somewhere in town like near the water
and whatever all the salt no all the
snow oh the snow on the bad storms when
the snow is so bad when they would clean
schools and dead ends and stuff like
that you would have to go around with
the frontend loader I would have two
dump trucks with me and I would load the
dump trucks filled with snow okay so we
were talking about snow I thought you
were talking about spreading salt well
it's the same kind of thing but the
spreaders couldn't fit down some of
these blocks okay so instead of getting
the spreader they go and actually try
and pick the snow up with with a front
and loader wow with we call them big
rubber tire machines you know
damn so I did that for pretty much the
whole career 18 years I was doing that
in the uh Winters oh so you do that in
the winter and then trash in the spring
no it's just when it when it comes up
you go you know you do it but that was
the fun part driving the front end Lotus
yeah that was good times man oh that's
cool cuz you didn't have to get out that
much huh no and you were like you were
like saving people that's when people
loved you ah dude there were areas where
you couldn't get down like spreaders
would slide off the road yeah we would
have to go wreck dragged them off off of
cliffs like it was crazy Winters were
nuts and then they were like all right
get a machine up there and it was like
the hills are like this bro wow and you
know I had this boss who always where's
where's
Owen like what do you mean they would
all all last names on the job they like
where's Owen get him on the horn let's
go get him in here cuz he knew I would
just tell everybody stay away cuz
everybody's out there shoveling throwing
the more Sal I mean uh snow into the
street making it more of a mess yeah
yeah and they he knew like he I'm going
to buckle up and here we go let's send
the Hitman in let's see what happens oh
hell yeah yeah hell yeah what's the what
type of attitude does someone have to
have or what skill set does someone have
to have or who would best be a be able
to be a garbage man a sanitation worker
oh it all it's listen it's about the
community you know when it all comes
down to it you know I still took pride
in like especially those days with you
know knowing that my mother had a drive
my family people friends have to drive
on those roads during the winter yeah so
yeah there were guys that would hide you
know and not spread salt but like me I
was out there 12 hours spread Sal I had
no problem with it so it's a it is a
sense of Pride that you know you work
for the city but in the same sense it's
there's not a you know I had a girl tell
me once on the job she's like you like
you like born for this job and I didn't
know how to take it like I was a little
taken back like like is it a good thing
that she's saying that or like am I a
piece of like I was just like I was
thrown away like I'm really thrown off
like I'm just like hey thanks yeah like
I I had nothing to say and she was cool
as she was awesome but CU we had
girls that did the job too really yeah
man wow and some of them I'd rather work
with some of them than some of the other
guys really yeah there would there were
you know women out there that were you
know Hustlers oh yeah you know and then
there were guys that you always thought
you would go to oh yeah you come work
with me you know jacked up yeah no he
just doing that for the girls really
help me I can't lift this trying to meet
the women on on the on the yeah they're
going to the gym all day pump an iron
but they can't lift you know a 100 PB
couch they used to swing couches like in
one shot oh yeah D you know that's
beautiful yeah I think it's like a In
some cultures a yeah that's like a
wedding ritual or something a man and a
woman throwing like I don't know what it
is was there a lot of intermingling on
the job or something you think oh there
was some yeah
I never partake in that lot of ladies
trying to put that dump you huh well you
got two pensions you know there were a
few body dumpster boy yeah they were on
me there were definitely a few and and
listen you look at it like I just said
you know you get two pensions B retire
oh it's a it's a good life you know
let's go to Florida and stay huh what um
yeah did people F did yeah was there
ever a couple that met on the job and
ended up yeah getting married yeah wow
we tired one one wound up being a boss I
don't oh his wife might have became a
boss but yeah you know listen it
happened love happens everywhere yeah
you're together a long time you're out
in the streets all day and and some guys
and girls hit it off what are some other
things people would collect out there in
the trash anybody find anything really
unique over the years any bone structure
or anything like that listen you'd find
all kinds of stuff if you were looking
like I said like you didn't look though
I didn't have for it like I said I was
running I want to get done I want to be
out of the street I don't want to deal
with people like I said the people that
don't pay attention to you they drive
into you right it's just risky hot you
know crabby days but this one time I'm
with my buddy you know Louie and we're
picking up this apartment building and
we open the gates and there's I think it
was six or seven Joker poker machines
and I'm like what the is this about
video poker yeah like in the bars you
know they have those you know used to
use our allowance in them yeah and so I
I worked got bars when I was younger and
I knew I'm like oh yeah the money
stashed underneath so we opened them up
there was nothing there but I'm like you
know what I remember one of the bar
owners having like a trap door because
sometimes the dollars know the $10 bills
would just float in and there was this
little Tupperware in there and it would
float float and it fall Perfect Right
Down the slit so when I saw that was
still blocked off we dragged them back
to the garage we beat the living piss
out of these things with with
sledgehammers my boss walks in he's like
I'm not even going to ask what's up
right dude got 360 a piece $720 uhuh D
and they were the finest 10 and uh $20
1980 bills oh yeah they were like right
out the machine oh that's beautiful so
yeah that was one of my better ones but
listen you find things here and there I
always found something that you know
somebody was throwing out and I didn't
have to dig like it was next to the curb
um I found a moped once in Manhattan oh
yeah on the side of the you know right
on the side of a basket um the corner
basket there
and it was probably from like a Chinese
restaurant something like that it was
like locked in to turn left so who's
going to just keep driving in a circle
kids must have stole it and they
realized ah we can't use this so they
left it at the corner basket right so I
told my partner I'm going to take this
and as we're putting it like I said
there's a little trapo as I'm putting it
in there the uh the cops pull up so
we're like oh and this guy I'm working
with like damn Owen you me all up
now I'm going to get locked up for this
right we're standing on the
stealing a moped from somebody you know
from some Chinese kid over here yeah
like the guy's laying there holding bags
and Nas so he's like they they just
pulled up they were like yo is it run
I'm like I don't know I'm going to see
brought that home broke the uh
steering collar and wound up getting it
started and I used to use it to go down
to the bodega down the block and grab
beers and yeah so that was a good
find yeah that's a good find yeah that's
interesting man yeah I'm trying to think
I think I would
like
I think I probably would like it when I
was young I had to do the trash at the
house you know I didn't mind
it you know just Home Sanitation or
whatever get it out to the curb you know
but I was a kid you know we'd never see
we never got to see the real artist pull
up in the early morning you know he was
still asleep or something or probably
just getting up for school well kids
love it too like they come out they want
to work the handles which what Happ like
that was a fad for a while where like a
lot of moms would do the uh Tik Tok
videos that a kid meets the garbage man
were you around for that yeah I had a
few like and I would get the kids stuff
like shirts and stuff I would always
give them back I would have kids that
like stand uh like at the glass door the
mother would hear us in the neighborhood
open the main door and then there's like
a sliding like a like a screen door with
glass and the kids just used to sit
there and I loved it you know you would
get parents all the time like oh of all
people my daughter loves you guys like
little kids you know I don't know kids
are fascinated with it and it's awesome
but at the same time it's like the
parents will probably like ah don't do
that you know don't grow up to be a
garbage man yeah because they don't
realize the money in it right you know
but now more people are going to know
it's a good business it sounds like you
have to have a you got to keep a
positive attitude though huh that's it
listen it the day goes by so much easier
if you just get through the work you
have a good partner good relationship
with your partner it's awesome listen
there's so many other shittier jobs like
I would take that over any City job in
New York really yeah like you got the
fireman you know they're just wearing
t-shirts trying to get free stuff oh
yeah and they're let's be honest
they're making they're just eating
Franks back in there exactly you know no
judgment I love these guys yeah no 100%
my brother-in-laws one's retired one's
still on I got a lot of friends that do
it I just bust their chops all the time
because they're always wearing a fire
department T-shirt I'm like dude you got
no other clothes in your yeah oh they
definitely they yeah and then
you light a match and they're
over there beating up a birthday cake
just just to Flex a little yeah
fireman's here yeah yeah somebody's got
but meanwhile I laugh I'll talk about my
brother-in-laws quick my wife's Brothers
they'll come to my house and I got a
fire pit in the yard dude it's like
they're trying to light my house on fire
it's like bro what don't you put these
out why you starting this this big
like my and I got like a tin roof over
Metals melting I'm like dude what's the
point of this yeah yeah your bird feeder
bro you're looking your bird feeder you
got a grilled SP
yeah it's like dude what are you trying
to prove are you trying to put another
fire out here do that on their time not
mine a lot of firemen are closeted uh
pyromaniacs pyromaniacs arsonist Barn
burners whatever they're called bro
flame babies whatever they call them bro
crazy oh yeah a bunch of
kerosene mammals bro they don't give a
dude they'll drink kerosene
and then blow a flamethrower
they don't give a dude them guys
and the cops it's tough man I feel be
New York cops do you I got a lot of
friends you know listen there there's
bad apples all over this I don't care
what industry you're in people are
idiots the way they act the way they you
know treat people yeah but just I I it's
just crazy how they treat New York cops
like when I was growing up you respected
the cops yeah that was it you on
the garbage man you respect the cops
yeah but now it's like I just don't get
it so those are two jobs I don't even
want yeah I think the media's LED a lot
of that happen you know I think you have
a lot of like the same types of uh folks
doing a lot of crime that don't have any
respect for police officers I think uh
you have a lot of kids raised with no
families yeah no parents they don't have
any respect for anybody so and the
people that were supposed to be in their
you know Authority is they in fact hate
Authority because they never had any so
it's like the second they see a cop you
know yeah it's heartbreaking dude yeah
what a lot of those guys go through do
you have a relationship with police fire
the other the other like municipality is
that what it's called no what's it
called yeah uh Civil Service the other
civil service yeah of course you know
they always you know they always call up
they got to throw stuff out you know
during the winters you know the police
department was always like you had to go
do the police department and that was
like even the ferry in Staten Island you
had to go hit that with the plows and
everything get all that spread you know
salt spread it down you know I would
always go to the fire departments you
know so you take a you take a spreader
onto a ferry no it's like the ramps to
get on the ferry so like where all the
buses come in yeah you know that that
you have to hit all those ramps and I
mean it's non-stop it's like one truck
does that all day goes up and down the
main road and then comes back and hits
all those Bays to make sure that all the
buses you know I had this bus you know
back into me once I'm like dude you
didn't see this big truck like I got
blinking lights everywhere yeah oh it's
my fifth day on the job I felt bad for
the K he probably got fired I did feel
bad for him but they drove right into
the plow I'm like oh man but yeah you
respected each other you know and you
know I got pulled over a few times here
and there you know for stupid like
tint in my windows and stuff like that
all right don't worry about it basic
Asian crimes really I call those yeah
every time I get stopped for that um
what type of ethnicity is a garbage man
A lot of times we had black and white
men mostly is it every ethnicity or is
it is every so it's a real Universal Job
yeah we had the most diverse in the city
that's the most diverse City job and it
was dude it was fun man I had a lot of
fun yeah met a lot of cool people huh a
lot of cool people a lot of fun people a
lot of guys I still talk to oh yeah you
know that's so cool man I think there is
something about the camaraderie what was
it like when you got back to like the
the the house or whatever you you know
was there a uh what was that like was
there a shop or something where would
you guys all get back to and hang out
was there like a bunk house yeah you
always had like a an area where you know
you would have couches you know which
there was like rules like oh don't sit
on it in your city uniform like nasty
but you know people always did did they
it's gross n people would go do the
trash route and then come and yeah and
then come and lay down on the couch it's
like dude what what are you doing oh my
God bro that makes me so sad and then
you listen you know even the bathrooms
in some of these places like I always
wanted I wanted to do like a study and
go to guys houses and see how they react
like how they are around their families
cuz I'm like if you do this here and you
don't clean up after yourself like you
know what do you do home yeah like does
your wife wipe your ass like I don't get
it oh you know the wife's probably glad
they not at home oh anybody ever have a
wife that killed them while they were on
a job that you knew anybody work nothing
like that yeah a lot of divorces they
used to say it's cheaper to keep them
really that was the going saying like
but oh you get marriage cheaper to keep
them yeah guys coming in with like
paychecks for
$1.99 like cuz that's how many baby
everything
oh do you guys compete against other uh
Civil Service Groups like is there like
a volleyball squad or anything no we
used to do like a softball thing within
like on St Island there's uh three
garages we used to do that for a few
years but nothing like you know other
than that yeah what uh does your son
want to be at garbage man when he grows
up
no believe it or not my oldest doesn't
even remember me being a gage man I used
to bring the truck I used to bring that
but he was young you know and now in I
think I want I want to say I left Staten
Island six years ago so he was four so
he's still young you know so you had 20
years of service man you got it done you
look so young I mean you had 20 years of
service you got in and got out retired
at 41 wow uh started my own you know
construction I do bathrooms kitchens all
that stuff oh yeah and then my back went
out oh so I've been on the shelf for
right now getting back in the game are
you on pain pills or not no good I don't
mess with that Amen brother no I
went on the medical marijuana for a
while just to take gummies oh
yeah okay you got a piss too yeah I'm
almost all right let's go all piss and
then we'll come back up and finish up is
that cool yeah okay great whatever you
want to do yeah what does the uh
retirement look like what does a
retirement look like so you get yeah
they give you like a uh watch or a
jacket is it like a big thing you get a
pension you don't get nothing from them
you get the pension you get a pension
pension uh health benefits okay all all
paid for life for your family until you
yeah until you until you're gone wow
dude that's incredible so there a lot of
value there yeah everybody like passes
that over you know when guys are like oh
I got to stay on the job I got to do 25
because it's my pensions only this now
but they don't realize how expensive
insurance is yeah you know at least two
grand for four people
me my wife my kids yeah so you know like
you said it's it's money yeah oh yeah
shoot that's more people people pay as
much to insure themel you know it's some
people's more than their mortgage than
their rent yeah um so you get that
you're done what do you do you're 41
years old you just retired from a job
pretty
incredible how what makes you decide to
go into uh like home construction and
stuff like that I grew up around it my
father owned the hardware store growing
up
really yeah oh it's so cool so I had
every tool in the shed I had everything
you know and five six years old I was
using saws oh yeah cuz they didn't have
no safety on it back then oh yeah
somebody breaks in your home you
skill saw them my mother would scream
get away from that cuz my father was at
work so I would just I made my I think I
was eight years old I was building a
treeh house yeah of course bro my wife's
like me my my mother like what are you
doing I'm like like I'm just building a
treehouse you're like this treehouse
ain't going to build itself
exactly kicked the step slit my head
open that was the end of The Treehouse
wow yeah but yeah I I just love working
like with Woodwork and you know all that
stuff um is your father still alive he
is oh wow still doing it great dude I
never you know but you know then he went
into different things you know he became
a court Runner as well he used to run
around for a law firm you know he did
that and then you know and he started
working with me that was about three
weeks couldn't take that no more so
he's still doing home improvements he's
he's actually doing a bathroom right now
oh amen I'm like dude you're crazy yeah
but he likes to work though yeah he's
always is always you get enjoyment out
of it you know when I do kitchens and
bathrooms for people you feel it you
feel more you know just the the wow and
oh my God you could do this like I yeah
yeah yeah I think it's something that
that that that's missing from my job too
A lot of times is the Fe is that
physical feeling of completing something
you know that construction the building
yeah you know there's definitely
something inside of us that wants to uh
to build or complete something um I
think for a lot of us anyway um yeah my
mother loves to work she just I'm always
like Mom can I help you out can I do
she's like you know I need to get a new
van so I can keep doing my deliveries
you know it's like hey what look you
want somebody to be happy you know you
want them to do what they want
um yeah people always there's always
that thing you don't want to end up
being a garbage man you know was that
did that always did that ever make you
feel bad you didn't think anything about
it did you was there
any oh listen everybody you know would
say oh you're garbage man this and that
and like I said always look down but
listen I I didn't give a yeah I was
making good money yeah you could do
whatever you want I don't give a
and your job sounds honestly as CRA it
sounds fun dude dude it was awesome dude
I got I didn't even get into craziness
but it really was it's like you're on
your own it's you or your partner the
garbage truck you just pick up garbage
they give you a route here's the blocks
it's a Bless yeah and it's all dude I
used to clip on a a like a speaker 6:00
in the morning you hear me coming down
the block that shit's blasting dance
music rap music yeah like bumping yeah
picking garbage up having fun I never it
I never like bothered me once there are
people on the job that hate it really
yeah like that you know oh I don't tell
people about this I was like you know I
I didn't it's not HPV dude yeah I'm like
J exactly somebody's got to do it but
yeah I I loved it we got into a real
quick story I but my buddies come flying
up a one way and now me and my buddy
Louis we're down like it's what point
down the one way they come flying up the
wrong way I'm like what the is
going on here I said oh maybe they're
coming to help us cuz you used to do
that all the time on the job you call
out the friends Hey listen my route's
heavy today right like can you come and
grab this block yeah no problem you
always help each other out D all a
sudden these two they jump out the truck
they start whipping us with eggs uh-uh
it was like around Halloween it might
have been Halloween right so they're
chucking eggs B B all over the truck I'm
running yeah like they're throwing eggs
at us and me and my buddy Lou actually
I'm garbage and Louis goes running by me
I'm like where' you go and then eggs
start flying over my head so now we fly
up the block they back out they they
drive away right so now you always have
blocks that intertwine yeah so they go
the main street we go to the store get
two dozen eggs we go all these shortcuts
cutting every light off we block you
know we just ran we waited for them
where we knew they were going to go and
now regular Earth is happening like
people are out at the there's a food
store right there yeah there's people
walking the streets everything dude
we're hiding behind cars and they pull
up and get stuck at the light dude we
whipping oh yeah they were covered head
to toe they couldn't get out they were
blocked in by cars where we had the
chance to run we had to go back to my
mother's house and wash the inside of
the cabs out that's how bad it was like
hagging now that's crazy man but no oh
that's fun yeah nobody's even paying
attention to you that's fun dude
oh that's cool and could you listen to
music in the fac in the uh vehicle
there's no music in there yeah no you
would bring radios in on your
own you would get like a radio or boom
box or something like
that but you listen to what you wanted
to you know country music was my thing
you know later in my role yeah and when
I first started you know I was I used to
get yelled at in one area because the
music was too loud oh yeah yeah cuz we
would pump it listen you got to make the
best of your day oh I think so too music
helps everything for sure yep um what's
good and bad about the unions like about
unions what is that whole setup like can
you talk about it if you don't feel
Comfort that's okay yeah I mean it's
it's CU you're in the Union right well
no because now the city pays me I'm not
really in the union anymore I'm done
it's not like a I don't understand
unions fully so maybe do you even have
any explanation to me about what union
because you were part of a union right
yeah yes I was okay so how does that
even H for some jobs you have to be in a
union to have the job yeah certain
businesses run under Union standards
okay which means you have to pay dues um
and you know whatever it is monthly you
pay dues and and you stay in good
standard within the union now you know
and then you get into like iron workers
and all that those unions are totally
different okay because those unions are
paying those guys pensions okay to me
when I worked for New York yes we ran
for a union like there's a different
Union for us the fire department the
police department everybody has their
own Union but once I'm done I'm out of
that Union and now the city just sends
my checks okay like they I have nothing
to do with the Union anymore I don't go
to meetings I don't you know pick at
line or I don't do all that nonsense no
more did you guys ever have to strike we
couldn't we were signed under the tailor
law okay so the tailor law you can't
strike if you know you you could lose
that's the one way you could lose your
job you could it was crazy dude the job
you could never lose the job what I'm
dead honest literally I knew guys that
killed people that worked on the job
yeah they went to prison their pions are
still waiting for them when they come
out but the thing is if you were dirty
if you came up on drugs and Stu on an
accident and somebody got hurt that's
probably the only way you can lose your
job I see so but the unions it's tough
It's listen they're great it's just it's
a it's expensive yeah what type of
injuries happen on a job to guys a lot
like I said I had uh my my left knee
miniscus surgery my right Rotator my
left uh clavicle like I I busted up and
it's just from swinging bags yeah and
then my back of course was just a matter
of time oh yeah you know once I stopped
running around the streets picking
garbage up and now I'm doing my side
well not my side but I was doing my
kitchens and bathrooms at my speed not
running four miles every day my back
just locked up on me so I had to go in
in a knife was it uh was it hard to
adjust whenever you retired yeah
retirement everybody oh I'm gonna retire
it's not worth it that's why I'm going
to start working again back in the back
of the trash no no no no sanitation no
I'm I'm actually looking now just to get
into something simple nothing crazy you
know I'm not one of those oh I need a
big high paying just something basic I
just want to stay busy yeah because it's
honestly dude it's not healthy when
you're sitting around yeah you're just
sitting around you know it's good for
two or three days and then you're like
oh yeah I'll give it like two weeks
yeah but then you're like now what and
yeah I neighbors you're taking a cat for
a walk or something like what the
am I doing ex you know yeah you're
selling lemonade in your
driveway getting sad nickel of
Peace yeah you're out there selling
lemonade during from 1: to 2 p.m. no my
wife thinks I'm crazy because I take my
lawn very seriously oh yeah first thing
the guy who's retired does
my lawn's this I need more water
I need more this I need this oh you're
crazy but what else am I going to do
where did you meet your wife did you
have her before you had the job no oh no
I was on the job I think five years wow
when I met my wife just a bar scene I I
would bring something up and she would
kill me if I told you well I'll tell you
but you can't play it on the sign you
can't play it okay I promise met her
there you know hello this that's about
it mhm then I started seeing around the
bars my buddy and were you partying back
then or no I was partying oh yeah me it
was ugly oh bro I you find me in
a just a neighborhood
house party just do snorting stack or
twos and holding holding up a
wall but see that's that's the old like
stat now like I said we were in bosss 15
16 years old bro oh yeah so like it
started getting boring at 2122 yeah but
she was in college on Staten Island went
to Wagner College and she was always in
the bars mhm my buddy God Rest his soul
you know didn't do so well with that
party and end and uh he was dating her
friend so she was like oh you got to
date Wayne you got to date Wayne
whatever you know we finally I'm Wayne
yeah I'm Wayne I'm here I'm the
guy but and then we just hit it off you
know we started bu you know bullshitting
she was tell people she'd probably still
tell you today like oh he was following
me around I'm like you probably were you
no but you you're I'm five years older
than you I've been in these bars for 10
years longer than you yeah don't tell me
that these are my bars right this you're
I think when you're tall people can
always see you wherever you are I'm
always above right so people always like
oh that guy's following me like I'm not
following you I'm just over here
yeah it's like that's the shitty part
about being tall right that's a good
point but now when did you break when
did you tell your wife that you were
working as a garbage sanitation work did
you have to sit her down and tell her oh
no she knew okay yeah she pretty much
knew but she must have it sounds such
like a for somebody to be able to get up
that much go do that job I think there's
a ton of admiration in it probably you
probably have to start to admire like
this guy gets his job his work
done well it's not easy in the sense
that like you say it's you have to it's
a commitment for 20 years or more I know
guys 25 30 years um but it's more of
like you wake up and all you hear is
downpouring you still got to go
so it is and like I never wanted a pat
on the back like screw that you know it
was just more of knowing like how your
days going to go from the minute you
wake up hearing pouring rain or you know
it's going to snow today all right well
I'll see you tonight at 8:00 at night
and you're leaving at 6: in the morning
I wouldn't get home 8 n o'clock at night
wow so there was and listen it was good
money I think her family knew like oh
yeah I'm dating this guy who works for
sanitation oh that's a great job it's a
city job like it's known right
but yeah you don't know that I mean
that's one of the things that I'm so
happy to learn is like you don't know
that there's uh you can make good money
you don't know that there's a pension in
it you don't know that you can
have a good time you don't know that you
get over the smells you don't even
notice it anymore huh no wow don't even
notice it and I could pick it out anyway
like could you smell different types of
trash from certain amounts of feet away
you know what it is the maggot smell
like I was saying is the killer you know
and there are sometimes I have a
backyard you know that we eat outside we
throw the garbage and I don't throw it
out right away it's like in a bag in a
pal dude maggots will start crawling out
of the pale maggots are gross huh awful
I used to I used to be walking around
there all my
arms they would they would come out of
the truck Splat on your AR like nasty
like blowing them off your arm while
you're on the back of the truck it's
part of the job was there like a wave of
trash water that would come out on the
cycle like I'm talking something Kelly
Kelly Slater would flirt with you
know so this so this woman and I knew
her from the neighborhood I went to
school well I didn't go to school with
her daughter but I knew her daughter
from high school M and I used to hang
out with her and her friends and she
comes out she's like oh Wayne I got can
I can't lift the sofa and it was in the
driveway I'm like yeah I'll get it go
back inside
downpour so we throw the sofa in and we
throw bags in now she's right next to me
and I'm like don't stand there go
somewhere else no no no no I want to get
she was trying to help give us something
you know for taking this stuff let give
you a couple muffins or something it's
Cycles dude from head to toe was brown
Water she literally had maggots like on
her face I was like get in the house
yeah and go take a shower she's like
what is all this I was with her eyes
closed oh I'm like just get in the
house I told you don't stand
here you know that's the Devil's Back
wash I mean you don't want that it just
happened cuz we were uphill and and the
rainy days now you're lifting reped it
doesn't have a lid water's going in and
it's just squashing around it's it's
like sewage it's
disgusting and all that water just is
there a catch from the truck or it all
goes on the street usually no well we
used to have drain pipes but then they
slded like they uh welded them all shut
because like they didn't people would
complain that trash was like coming out
on the street so you had to deal with it
our thing was you wanted to find a
mattress at that point so you would
throw the mattress in squeeze it and
would sop up all the water on the bad
days so there's some there's some
strategies to the game listen just
because we're goge man a we ain't stupid
yeah of course not yeah I never think
that those guys are dumb I don't know
what I think I think it's just also the
the tough part about that job is if
you're just like someone who lives
somewhere you don't get to go so quick
you know it's tough to get time with
them you know like you don't you know
like cops stay around and you
know T you or whatever with you
or like in a neighbor yeah when I was
growing up like some girl would you know
a cop would always be flirting with
somebody's some lady or something her
husband's missing or whatever and they
probably did it but they ain't telling
nobody and now they're over here
flirting and splitting you know
cutting up donuts with a plastic knife
on the hood of the Cruiser you
know flirt with Miss Cheryl over here
who's always all dude this lady by us
would get all liquored up she'd
be drinking daquaries and she'd uh lay
she'd start her car she had this
like car that was like a hot rod or
something she'd start that and
then with these short shorts and then
lay on the hood of it dude
say like pervy out loud
like don't you miss me she'd say don't
you miss me and we don't even
know her like who the is this lady
I'm eight I'm but uh we sit out
there and watch her bro you know listen
everybody has their thing but yeah cops
you get to you end up talking with them
you know you know there's some there's
some communication but y'all's job it's
kind of just hit and run it's hit and
run and even the guys I have now you
know like I give them a $100 tip during
Christmas MH listen I did the job like I
you know I know it sucks the Rainy Days
yeah there's good days there's a lot
more good days than you know the rainy
days and and once you get wet you get
wet you're done um but like I have
people now tell me what do you mean you
tipped them I'm like dude it's they you
these guys who pick my stuff up that's
private they're not making what I was
making in the city you know and it's
it's a lot man they're still they're
doing you a service and they always say
everybody's always you know line was oh
well I'm you know that's their job they
have to pick it up they got to take it
and I would tell people this ain't my
job you know I'm here to pick up your
household garbage I'm not here to take
all your demo from your construction job
on your house and that was always where
the fine line of like arguing fighting
with people like I ain't going to fight
with you it's garbage like why are we
fighting over garbage right just get a
dumpster and I'm not picking this up
yeah case settled done you somebody
tried to go to blows with you or
something yeah a few times women or men
well the woman the it was a husband and
wife and they had bags of tile out M and
the bags and get the out of here
with that she was just an this
woman and literally the tile is sticking
out the bag oh yeah so that's like razor
blades porcelain tile I don't know if
you ever been cut by porcelain it sucks
and she's like oh you're not going to
take this yeah it's your job I said
listen this I'm not taking the you
can throw it in oh fine I'll throw it in
yeah look big strong guy you know uh
sanitation worker can't throw it in but
I could and she's rubbing it all up on a
belly and I'm like good look at you
you animal you know turns out she's a
nurse oh yeah nurse biscuit all
morning that bit out of her mind
bro sorry that's kind of mean I'm
getting mean no and she says you know
and it was up what she said she
was like you know you know what if you
ever come into my hospital and you need
help you know you uhuh I said you
and now like I said I'm not a blow my
top it's garbage well I'm not going to
fight with you you want to throw it in
throw it in I don't give a I said
you know what you yeah right
to her face and I closed the
hopp her and she still had 10 15 bags
left and I drove away I told my
partner
drive my boss calls he's like what are
you doing I said let me guess the nurse
called he's like I don't know who the
nursse is but this woman called and you
know she's calling she got 311 on the
line this and that and I'm like dude
this is what she said to me so I blew my
lid and told her to go herself yeah
he's like listen my boss calls he's like
just let her throw the rest of the bags
in I'm like I don't want to go back
there so we went back anyway wow because
I just don't want to deal with I don't
want to fight on my other end so I go
back there now her Burly 68 husband's
there uhuh and he gets in my face right
and I'm like dude you do not want to do
this I said listen I'm a garbage man
that's all fine and dandy but you don't
want to see what part there is yeah my
old 67 year old partner jumps out the
truck gets right in his face starts
pushing him nuh he's like dude you get
the back in the house we'll throw
the in get the out of my
partner's face yeah I was like good for
you yeah good for you but you had that
here and there yeah people want to fight
it's garbage what are we fighting over
garbage for yeah so wild man it's
interesting I'm trying to think if
there's anything else I that I I don't
know or want to understand about the job
oh if you had boots on how did you keep
the water from getting into the boot
trash water like I said you had rain
boots but those were regular boots but
just been soaked since and you just put
them like on top of your locker hope
they dry by the next rainstorm cuz
they're if not wet boots suck but what
are you GNA do there's one time this guy
goes why you running through the street
it was raining I said because I hate wet
boots I turn around I'm like I I think I
said something like I hate wet boots you
know what you know that feeling I turned
around I didn't realize he was in a
wheelchair uhuh I'm like this
probably can't even feel
his legs I'm like damn it but he ain't
got to worry about wet boots either
exactly but that's the thing it's like
dodging you you tell people I'm dodging
raindrops yeah oh yeah but everything
got
wet DOD your rain drops that's a good
term um so your wife was good with it
what kind of line of work did she get
into she was in medical sales um medical
device sales so like when you have
surgeries and stuff she sold all like
the nuts bolts and stuff for a company
but now she's doing it back again she
had went to just into sales for uh like
smaller companies but now she's back
doing medical device nice you know she's
she's always been a hard worker yeah my
wife I'll give her a shout out Wendy
she's always been a hard worker you know
our kids are awesome Parker and Jackson
with an ex Jackson with an ex yeah like
uh
Jackson who's the starting quarterback
for Old
Miss
[Music]
Jackson Dart is that one an X is that JX
n JX n yeah no we left the S off oh wow
yeah yeah dude Jack's on you're
like Elon Musk dude yeah wild and
okay got you a family D Parker and
Jackson yeah have you enjoyed being a
dad is it exciting love it yeah that's
the only that's like the shitty part
about now going back to work you know I
love having my boys in the morning my
Jackson my six-year-old's hysterical
dude oh really oh from 530 30 on bro he
does not stop and we joke with the
10-year-old he joke all the time we're
like dude we there's got to be an off
button and it's d d da like do you see
this d da asking me questions like while
I'm getting lunch ready for them and
breakfast and it's just nonstop yeah but
I love it yeah I don't mind any part of
it
like I I do anything for them of course
because they're my kids but like that's
going to be the hardest part of me like
missing now the mornings and then
missing when they get home from school
that's going to be you know if I start
getting home later that's going to be
the shitty part
yeah yeah it's a bummer a lot of people
have to deal with that you know I think
it's just it's it's unfortunate that
that's kind of how societ our society is
you know I wonder if we're supposed to
be like that or what you know like human
beings are supposed to be like
um you know like you know you think
about the old days of like when people
probably lived around a campfire and
everybody was home but you were
living around a campfire too you know so
I think there was probably
probably interesting um yeah what would
you say to somebody who's thinking like
could I be a a sanitation worker oh more
power to you yeah listen like I said
it's a New York thing if you live in the
tri- state you know in New York not Tri
State if you live in New York it's like
a known thing take all the tests it's
the best thing I know a buddy of mine
his daughter came on he waited long
enough cuz his daughter did so good on
the test that his daughter got on the
job uhuh they got to work together so
they got to work together it was a big
thing by the the city you know they went
out and then he retired like a week
later you know so like it listen you
know when you know what's coming of the
job you know how good it is but you
don't want to tell people yeah we always
said don't tell nobody how good this job
is and here you are and and yeah there
are all grueling shitty Parts about it
but the job was great man yeah like I
would never curse the job in that aspect
of it well the fact you had to win a
lottery to even get a chance to take the
job is freaking pretty unreal well now
they don't do that no more now they
allow all them to take the the test and
take the you know and see how the lists
are M um but there's 120,000 people
taking the test now that shows you how
much people want this and like somebody
called me they're like oh yo my nephew
took the test I'm like all right how do
he do oh he's got a 93 I'm like oh
what's his list number 40,000 like he's
done like dude the job has to die six
times over yeah there's 6,000 guys on
the job so everyone has to go to work
that day die the next day 6,000 die like
so do he really I said if you got a 40
if you got that kind of number on that
test you should look for a different
professional gosh yeah that's that's
you're not it what was it like during Co
doing trash do you remember I just
retired oh you did so you got to miss
that the guys loved it they did they
loved it the money was crazy these guys
I'm telling you I know a guy moved to
Florida 990,000 a year 995,000 a years
ret pensioners he's almost bringing six
figures and retired how do you get your
pension to be higher you they take your
out of five years they take your best
three years and average it so if this
dude was doing you know 2 two2 you know
now they add that in and and the average
is 100 Grand wow you know so that's what
you get half of it so you get half of
your base you know for three years so
this guy's got another buddy you know
80,000 for the year that's what he's
going to get every year plus the
benefits and all that m he'll get
880,000 a year how long does a pension
last until you die uhuh but you could we
got to get it but take the test you got
to get a New York address though yeah
and I wouldn't do that but uh I taxes to
they crush you that's crazy bro but uh
but yeah it's that's part of it though
you you build up your pension to you
know get to a point where you'll leave a
lot of guys don't leave like I I said
earlier like they don't make it to it
you know so but you could also sign off
like I could have given my wife like a
percentage of my pension for the rest of
her life but it's just see how she does
yeah well you know little early for that
I'm not going to count her yeah
exactly Wendy's good yeah Wendy will be
fine now what if you die like doing like
in the line of service or whatever does
your wife like get a flag or anything do
they like do they is there like a um
yeah what's that like
they really don't I mean granted it's a
sad thing they do a whole memorial thing
like they like line the streets with
sanitation workers when they're bringing
a casket like any F or yeah um but it's
nothing like I told you they get I think
two years of service so two years of pay
so if they get 120,000 that's it you
don't get their no cuz you're going yeah
wow so if that's not in line in then you
die like if you're working it's not the
way it rolls wow yeah I know a guy you
know unbelievable he they forced them to
the clinic we had this clinic at work
where you would go and these quack
doctors would tell you you feel better
then they're like you know it's like
they got the the Jedi oh yeah oh
you feel good go back to work if you
were hurt MH and they forced this guy to
work and he dropped dead on the
stand on fa going to the going to the
clinic I felt awful for his wife and he
was such a good dude why and who has
those crack doctors the city because
they want you back on they want you back
on the job so the I think the city what
they do is they they look for guys that
lost their private practices like as
doctors and they they hire them for
pennies on the dollar so they hire those
people then yeah and they're quack
doctors wow they suck yeah D I had my
finger um I was picking up one night and
now you you know you're running through
the streets because it snowed so now
you're finally picking garbage up and
not a lot of people put put garbage out
after the snow it's like they become
like Hermits and just stay in their
house so they don't have garbage throw
out I grab a sewing machine I throw it
in the truck and it it still had a
needle so it fish hooked my thumb so my
whole thumb like flapped over this way
blood pouring down my arm MH so I go
have stitches I literally still had the
stitches in my finger and they're like
oh you could go back to work wow so you
have to kind of threaten them like all
right cool put your name here cuz when I
get gang Green from work oh you could do
desk work in the garage I'm like dude
it's the dirtiest place on earth a a
garage and a sanitation you know garage
it's gross you know so the desk and just
filthy nobody cleans
them so until you threaten them with
like oh I'll get a lawyer you know I'll
sue your ass all I take another few days
off yeah like it's just that's crazy you
have to threaten to sue doctors
who are just trying to get you back out
there you can't even take care of
yourself but then you have the other
side of the coin where guys will sit out
for try to sit out for seven
years because they got a you know they
got a Hip Flex or whatever I had a he
had like his cut that he would go
outside the building and scrape it
against the building outside and just go
back in and get another three days still
bleeding doc okay take another three
days damn it's like dude but then it
sucks because there's guys that are
up yeah you know like they
threatened my job once when I really
hurt my back I had my shoulder done and
they were like oh you we're going to
force you off the job cuz I was on light
duty and for like 18 months wow and
it's like you're going to force me off
the job like I'm in the year 16 like
what they didn't give a you're a number
that's it could people any handicap
people do your job is it can people in a
wheelchair be a garbage man or no not a
wheelchair per se but I think there was
some handicap on the job
yeah yeah the way they well a lot of
autism people do the job too I wouldn't
doubt it you know listen autism it's
nothing uh you know laugh about joke
about my both my kids are on the
Spectrum oh yeah we're on it but they're
awesome you know I was probably on it
yeah like you said they didn't test for
that back in the day no dude
we were just on it well that's what they
were like when we grew up they were like
oh he's either shy oh he's shy or oh
he's crazy like you were either
one or the other it was they never said
like oh yeah he's going to be an
astronaut like you know like he's real
smart no he's shy sits in the corner the
other kids hopping off the
walls and that's what it
was yeah you yeah you you just hope that
you had something in the middle probably
or at least that God gave you one of
each you know balance all your adhd's
Elemental PS all that oh now you
got a kid yeah you don't even
know dude you know it's unreal
these days the letters they come up with
it's just it's it's almost like the
other group oh yeah it's just like come
on man how many more letters do you g to
you know it's just everybody get
everything dude yeah I agree like you
got a guy who's the
DHD r e b you know r p c
tbq I'm like what you're a just
say you're a gay Beyonce F you know what
I'm saying
like what is just everything's
crazy now man dude it's nuts man yeah
look at this this this is the term now
lgbtqq I p2s A A up down up down select
start select start so you're a contra
Fant
no it's crazy they got a bat flying
around in here oh yeah bro that's free
bats dude from the city that's our
pension bro also it's getting close to
Halloween yeah so they're flying around
so we let them so they got somebody what
was it like what were some of the
holidays like the what was the Hol was
there a holiday or was there a day of
the year when you got the most
trash after any holidays so like because
you would skip the pickups I see so like
Christmas if we were off they would pick
up the next night okay and we used to
have to go in 1200 to 8 to go pick pick
it up and honestly they would steal
garbage like I my first year on the job
I never realized that guys stole garbage
wow so because on those days you just
had to load the truck as fast as you
wanted to as you can and then you were
done for the night okay so dudes would
literally it was like smoke coming out
of the tires take off out of the garage
go throw hustle get as much garbage as
you can and then just to be done you
load all you know top off your truck
you're done for the day and you're
stealing garbage then you pull up like
now I don't know anything I pull up to
the and it's all gone I'm like oh some
nice person took all my garbage yeah but
then they're like oh yeah now you have
to go do more house to house stuff
because they took all your big heavy
sausage bags so now you got to literally
look for garbage oh it's like hide and
seek for garbage and wow but it was
just get as much as you could fill your
truck up you're done yeah and that was
during the holidays right I did Y2K that
was a disaster yeah what was Y2K like
for a garbage I had three months on the
job they loaded us they were like oh
everybody go to this um this garage
Manhattan 7 on the west side so I'm like
all right cool near Time Square oh we'll
be out there for Time Square it's going
to be awesome I was so happy I signed up
and I'm looking at my watch I'm like y
I'm just get hanging out here with you
guys Happy New Year CU they didn't send
us out there till like almost 1:30 cuz
they didn't know if the world was going
to end well not even that they just let
the you know everybody like leave now
Time Square then we come in and clean up
oh yeah and by the time we got out there
dude that was the first time I thought
like wow people really do like us like
chicks wanted pictures with us like with
brooms like there people taking pictures
with chicks drunk and they're
banging on the Windows of the big bus
that we come in like oh yeah sanitation
here meanwhile I'm like what the
man I thought I was going to be in Time
Square Bull Drop sick n now I'm coming
in cleaning up piss bottles and on
the floor oh yeah but that was a fun day
yeah you
know uh Sandy when that storm hit curcan
Sandy oh that was a nasty one that was
another you know they we were going down
there and helping people now their whole
Lawns their whole front their houses
were covered The Lawns they were
bringing everything out right couches
you know clothes I I felt bad for these
living room the whole living room on the
curve everything so we would do our
regular routes and then run over there
and help the people and like handpick
the garbage up so one day I told my boss
I'm like dude this is you're not down
there I'm down there this is useless
like there's piles of garbage we need
the big machines yeah like so he's like
all right listen they agreed to it so I
convoyed seven uh front and loaders down
there dude the first block I turn on I I
I almost cried like that's how you feel
for people like piles of man their
stuff their whole house is on the
lawn yeah and we're just coming
in to throw it away oh so so
you're a service but even the service
you're providing is kind of painful yeah
it was shitty and uh but you get
Knuckleheads in New York like oh yeah
the St storm surge was coming and
they're like oh let's go see the waves
yeah cool dude they were $100,000 cars
littered all over the street with the
windows down that's how you knew they
got caught because there's a this thing
in cars now when it gets water damaged
the windows go down automatically so
somebody can't get caught in like a like
water or something like that oh yeah
make everything easy on people keys were
in them everything like the the key fobs
so this guy I knew he said they have a
chain on the front and loader I'm like
yeah so I had to hook trains up to like
brand new Audi Mercedes and
dragged them to clear the streets boats
in the middle of the road I it was like
playing with Tonka bro it was awesome
but I did feel bad in the sense of right
you still got to do all that but still
it was like it almost yeah it must have
felt like another Universe yeah I'm like
wow I'm dragging $100,000 cars around by
a chain hook him up to the tire the
wheels are screeching what about during
911 what was that like that sucked that
was shitty
um I didn't lose anybody but it was was
crazy because my sisters
sorry my sisters all worked in the city
mhm and we couldn't get in touch with
them oh so I had just gotten home from
work and I just worked 12 to 8 and my
buddy calls me and he's like dude this
idiot just you know flew into
the Trade Center I'm like what are you
talking about like I just got out of
shower like I'm just going I want to go
to bed I'm working 12 to 8 it's crazy
you know so next thing you know another
one comes my father calls me never heard
the guy cry in his life he and my buddy
at the time had a boat he's like get
that boat and put it in
the water he wanted to go get his
daughters and it was up the towns
were crazy they were going after
like all these Indian guys and all it
was crazy it was nuts wow and I was
supposed to go down there with a front
and to with a big machine and somebody
you could say stole it one of my buddies
jumped in the truck and took the
truck and uh he actually when he got
back he goes dude I helped you out he
goes that was the most awful
thing I've ever seen in my life cuz we
went right away and there was still
bodies laying around like parts and and
you know a lot of those guys wound up
with issues man you know with all kinds
of breathing issues and all kinds of
so it was shitty in New York at
that
point yeah because you guys have to did
you guys have to do some of the cleanup
or no we did some of it we did Hands-On
stuff like they didn't bring any
machines into a long time because they
was still looking for people yeah but
and we ran out of the landfill they put
these big tents up domes and they were
bringing material from there and dude
they were finding like a tooth yeah and
like claiming people CU there was so
many people missing and I knew a few
people like from the bar scene and
family friends that you know passed away
and it sucks it's just
shitty yeah and there was never really
any retribution I felt like in a weird
way also by America you know not that
there needs to be I'm not saying that
yeah but it was always like they never
exactly pinpoint you know it's almost
like they never even gave solace in that
sense no yeah it's you know it was like
a lot of people thought like that Saudi
Arabia was respon but there was you know
they kind of loosely blamed it on kind
of Ben uh
noin you get them all mixed up now it's
like who's next I know it's so shitty
you know but they Loosely kind of blamed
it on him and when and maybe he did do
it they just didn't tell it you know
it's like
man that was so weird to leave
America kind of hanging out to dry like
that too in a weird way like well who
the did this you you're not tell
you telling me you don't know yeah you
know somebody's got to know something
you know that night 22 people that were
involved in it who the did it and
there's so many crazy things like new
coming out like all this uh with
all these documents with it you know and
and I really even when it comes on I
can't even watch the anymore CU I
was there like saw the dust like from
Sten Island you know saw you know sort
all the dust and the uh smoke and stuff
but it's crazy now they're just come
they just keep digging up stuff now they
have new views of where the the planes
went in like people coming up with these
new camera angles um these Trade Center
buildings like nothing hit them seven
like the smaller ones how did it
collapse and now you're hearing this old
conspiracy theory that uh did like it
was worth oh I forgot who was the guy
who owned it like owed so much money or
something and it was all being put
through at that location also in
Washington DC where they hit the plane
there too there's so many theories out
there man and it's just shitty because
you did that you could have dropped the
planes at night right told everybody yo
fire alarm let everybody run if that was
the deal why why' you kill people and
but that's people because now that's
everybody's focus is on that yeah it's
not so much that why did these buildings
just collapse out of nowhere oh did so
and so own like owe money on it and this
was his way out yeah you don't I mean
there some people that's so dirty you
know and you some guy yeah who you could
give a guy a couple hundred dollars
he'll fly a plane into something some
dudes you know I know a crop duster
that'll you know that'll
zero in on your ex-wife's apartment dude
yeah for probably
600 for
sure um Wayne I think we've probably
learned everything that we can man it's
really
interesting um I wonder if it would be
really different in different parts of
America you think the job or do you
think it would probably be the same
across the board no I think it's
definitely different because it's on a a
private you know end where those guys
are making I work for a private I think
I was making $100 a day like just but I
was I got it down to two three hours so
whatever I was making 30 something
dollars an hour I didn't care but those
guys don't make the money like New York
there's certain I think uh like just
around me like Newark or Elizabeth like
where they're heavy unions they'll be
unionized but once you bring the
privates in if they're picking up your
GL uh your garbage probably here and
like in near my house they don't make
that kind of money yeah so it is it's a
different
animal and they don't even use guys like
I said they use the arm that lifts the
whole thing up dumps it in the truck
near my house yeah so it's definitely
different all over the country it's
changing man so even automation is
killing that industry huh yeah wow but
you have places like New York like I
said you can't right you can't there not
enough space right you're always gonna
need somebody yeah there's just not
enough space to get you know to the
garbage do you guys have beef with any
of the other like civil groups like is
any like do cops fire I me is there any
real beef out the streets or
it's kind of like I personally never had
an issue yeah like I said I said my
piece about the fan I'll probably get
from my friends for that one it's
funny dude but hey look bro you got
they know it's true yeah they
know it's true same bro same look it's a
lot of calendar models out there
bro it's a lot of dudes eating
hot dogs all day and then shooting up o
zimp you know so I wanted to do
it I wanted to do it once that uh I
wanted to do a calendar of like the big
guys on my job there some big
guys man really eating D but why could
wouldn't it be hard to beat a
garbage man big oh man dude well I just
told you you're sitting around eating
all day there's always cake there's
office guys big dudes man yeah I mean
four five 600
lb and some of them still wiggle down
the block oh there's not so much yeah
all you know they all find that spot
like oh I'm going to go work with this
guy or I'm gonna go work with that guy
like in an office or something yeah and
that's why it's like yeah you could say
that's what gave us like gives us bad
name of like oh yeah they're all just
fat ugly guys yeah and it's like no you
know there's a lot of guys on my job
that they don't really take care of
themselves they're lunatics with like
health and stuff oh yeah that's popular
these
days well look man I'm grateful for your
time man I feel like I learned a lot
about the job before I forget what about
uh drugs have people ever find any drugs
you
think no we always used to look in the
couches and stuff yeah because you never
know you hear stories of like bundles of
COA kilos and laying around I yeah
I've hidden drugs and couches and never
gotten it back yeah no I wouldn't doubt
it if they're out there yeah but no we
never that we used to say like oh yeah
thanks for the tip because change would
always come out oh yeah like nickel and
dimes and quarters and yeah but
people have lost like they Dro like oh
so and so and that's another part of
like I said with the tyvex suits so if
you drop something real quick if you
drop something in the garbage wedding
rings uh money anything expensive you
drop in the garbage you call the garage
hey I dropped on soand so block I
dropped something in the garbage
they'll call the truck out hey stop work
stop picking garbage up but you have to
dig through it nuh-uh uhhuh you do or I
do the owner the caller you want you
want your ring back no problem at at 10
at 5:00 tonight they're going to bring
that truck to a location on the landfill
in an open area they're going to dump it
all on the floor and have fun looking
have you gotten to watch somebody look
for something before I've seen like down
below cuz when we drop we drop into a
pit when we dumping s on and like there
was one family doing it you know they I
don't know if they ever found it they
family what a bunch of husband
yeah but I said family some
and you checking your
kid out of school to help you find all
the hands and eyes I could get yeah yeah
dude that's unreal but no I I knew a
woman she dropped 700 bucks she was
going to the bank and she put the
garbage out the hand the thing was in
her hand and it fell in the p and they
and she got it back wow she found it
they should play music and do a live
feed on that I would bet people would
pay to watch that bro and speed it up to
the yeah listen they do it they let
people do
it um Wayne I really appreciate it dude
thank you so much for your time brother
oh thanks for having me yeah it's
awesome yeah it's been really really
cool and um yeah I I think that it's a
it's an admirable feat and that some
people can do it and you can get in
there and get out with a pension and and
then go on the rest of your life yeah
you know definitely well worth it yeah
you heard it here first guys thank you
so much Wayne have a good one brother
you too thank you the yeah man now I'm
just floating on theze and
iing like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of my life
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's
going